Leute, soll ich euch mal die Wahrheit verraten?
Soll ich euch mal sagen, was Sache ist?
Ist doch keiner da, kann jetzt keiner hören, aber ich sag's euch jetzt einfach mal.
Ich sag euch jetzt, was Sache ist.
0w größer keckw.
Das ist einfach so.
Auch wenn die Popularität von keckw natürlich größer ist.
Aber 0w größer keckw.
Kein Spaß, Leute.
Cringe.
True.
True 0w, genau, so seh ich das auch.
Steam Deck hat Linux-Gaming geboostet.
Echt, Apex geht?
Das ist ziemlich pock.
Das wäre äußerst, das wäre wirklich sehr nice, wenn das funktioniert.
Wundert mich jetzt, dass das so schnell geht, aber das wäre auf jeden Fall cool, wenn das
geht.
Fehlt 0w und wisst ihr, was das Lustige daran ist?
Ich glaube...
Ah doch, ich hab 0w aktiviert.
Installier mal Serpentv, ne.
Das hat's von Anfang an bei mir verkackt, seit die irgendwelche Hitler-Bilder drin hatten
bei Serpentv.
Habe ich mir gedacht, ich weiß nicht, was es da mit der Emote-Genehmigung und Moderation
zu tun hat, aber wer weiß, was da für komische...
Oh, Moment, ich höre mich...
Sekunde.
Ha, Teams hat wieder meine Mikro rumgestellt.
Moment, ne, ist richtig alles.
Ich höre mich anders an, wirklich, Sekunde, muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max, mal gucken, was sage ich ja gar nicht mehr,
mal gucken, ob ich mich anders anhöre.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max, ne, eigentlich, eigentlich, eigentlich höre
ich mich, ich höre mich doch so an wie immer, oder?
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz, ich höre mich doch so an wie immer, oder?
In diesem Video nur ganz kurz, keine Ahnung, ja, vielleicht höre ich mich ein bisschen
anders an.
Ich muss immer noch ein bisschen husten zwischen, deswegen, Leute, ich muss hydraten, hydraten,
und ich futter ein Ricola, Schweizer Alpenkräuter, Alpensalbei, ist klar, das ist bestimmt nur
Salbei, was auf den Alpen gewachsen ist, ganz sicher, ja, ja.
Zockst du was?
Du meinst allgemein, oder jetzt im Stream, jetzt im Stream nicht, jetzt im Stream mache
ich das, was in der Kategorie steht, nein, heute, heute spiele ich nix, Onstream, wann
man basteln stellt, oder wir basteln an der Sache weiter, wo wir letztens angefangen
haben, weil ich mir dachte, da mussten noch ein paar Verbesserungen rein.
Du hast gestern was über C-Sharp im Geschäft erzählt, nutzt ihr das für die Automation,
oder sind da noch Sachen im Einsatz, was habe ich denn gestern erzählt, Pop-Schutz,
tja, wir müssen den Kram auch mal echt basteln, Leute, ich habe mir einen Schwamm gekauft
auf Amazon, da bauen wir einen Auto-Schwamm, ich habe so einen richtig dicken, fetten Schwamm
gekauft, den hier, ich glaube sogar den da, und, nee, nein, nicht der, meiner ist, meiner
ist nicht so grob, meiner ist nicht so grob, aber ich habe solche, ich habe Schwämme gekauft,
und davon baue ich mir einen Pop-Schutz fürs Mikrofon, weil mein aktuelles Mikro hat zwar
einen Pop-Schutz, aber der ist ziemlich unpop-schutzig effektiv.
Das dauert keine 10 Minuten, ich will jetzt aber nicht an meinem Schwamm rum schnibbeln
hier, das mache ich, entweder mache ich es morgen Offstream oder wir basteln das morgen
Abend schnell zusammen.
Was habe ich denn gestern noch mal erzählt, ah, ich weiß es wieder, ich weiß es wieder,
du meinst das mit der Log-Auswertung, kann das sein, meinst du das mit der Log-Auswertung,
weiß ich gestern, kennst du Obsidian, ich gehe mal davon aus, du meinst nicht die Minecraft-Steine,
du meinst den Hersteller, klar, Obsidian Entertainment, die haben relativ viele gute
Role-Playing-Games gemacht.
Haben die nicht sogar einen Fallout mal entwickelt, zwischenzeitlich, war nicht New Vegas oder
sowas von denen?
Ah, die haben hier eine Menge gemacht, Pillars of Eternity haben die gemacht, Note-Taking-Software,
nein, die kenne ich nicht, Obsidian Notes, nein, das sagt mir, ah, ein weiterer der 50
Milliarden Markdown-Editors, Pricing, ja gut, Online-Speichern von Notizen ist ja bei mir
eh schon mal außen vor, online gespeichert wird bei mir nichts, wenn ich hier schon sehe
Pricing, irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten für'n Arsch, will ich nicht, ich will nix online
speichern, das ist lokal, warum kann ich denn dann Pricing machen, ach, das ist einfach
zum Supporten oder was, ne, es ist doch Sync, natürlich kann ich Sync'en hier und online,
ne, ne, aber gut, wenn's lokal ist, warum nicht, hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert, also
ich bin mit Joplin eigentlich ganz zufrieden oder halt irgendein x-beliebiger Editor, mir
ist halt wichtig, dass ich den Kram im Zweifelsfall auch auf'n Handy gescheit verwenden kann dann.
Also, stimmt, also jetzt nochmal zu der Geschichte, die Radiosignal anspricht, ich hab gestern
erzählt, dass wir auf der Arbeit, dass ich, wir, es stimmt ja nur, dass ich eigentlich
zum größten Teil ein Squidlog-Auswertungstool programmiert hab, multithreaded, zum checken,
ob Firewall-Regeln noch gebraucht werden, ja, das hab ich gestern tatsächlich erzählt
und es gab nen Kollege bei mir, also der hat so nen Vorgänger programmiert in Bash, nochmal
so für die Leute, die gestern nicht dabei waren, der hat nen Vorgänger dieses Programms
in Bash programmiert, man kann ja in Bash auch durchaus komplexere Sachen machen, ein
riesen Nachteil von Bash ist aber, Bash ist halt langsam, es fuck, ich weiß nicht, ob
ihr schonmal ein bisschen komplexere Dinge in Bash gemacht habt, Bash ist wirklich richtig
langsam.
Man kann einiges noch optimieren, ja, wenn man unnötige Pipes vermeidet, unnötiges
rumkopieren und vieles quasi mit einem Programmaufruf als mit nem anderen, aber im Prinzip ist
Bash somit die langsamste Programmiersprache, die man sich so vorstellen kann, da ist aber
Python und Ruby richtig Burner, also richtig mega schnell dagegen, so und da haben wir
was zur Log-Auswertung programmiert für und das ging jetzt deutlich schneller, also die
Bash-Variante hat ungefähr ne Woche gebraucht und das.NET-Programm braucht ungefähr 45
Minuten über Terabyte von Logs, macht aber auch 12 Kerne bzw. 24 Threads, macht das komplett
dicht auf ner Kiste und auch alles im Ram, einfach, dass es schnell geht, ja, also nutzt
ihr das für Automation oder sind da noch andere Sachen im Einsatz, also hauptsächlich
müsst ihr sagen, benutze ich das für alles mögliche, also die meisten Sachen, die ich
auf der Arbeit entwickle sind, entweder halt, wenn es was für die Allgemeine ist, mal ganz
schnell was kurz und knackiges, ist das Bash-Script, aber wenn ich was ernsthaftes mach, ein bisschen
unfallreicher, ist das meistens ein.NET-Core-Programm und meistens dementsprechend auch in C-Sharp,
die schöne Sache daran ist, dass mittlerweile, du.NET-Programme relativ gut auch Single-Binary
veröffentlichen kannst, also kannst du sagen, hier kopier dir das und führs auf deine Linux-Kiste
aus und dann läuft das zurückliegend auf den letzten, was weiß ich, Linux-Körnern seit
2010 oder so, also das ist nicht verkehrt, die sind ein bisschen größer, die Sachen,
als jetzt beispielsweise ein Go-Programm, Go ist ja quasi so eines der Aushängeschilde
von Go ist ja so Static Binaries, das ist schön und gut, aber ich muss sagen, C-Sharp
ist für mich die deutlich angenehmere Programmiersprache als Go und klar, die Binaries sind ein bisschen
größer, aber letztendlich, ganz ehrlich, wen schockt denn am Ende, ob ein Binary 11MB
ist oder 40MB, jetzt kommen wahrscheinlich die C-Programmierer um die Ecke und sagen,
was, ein Binary 11MB, was ist denn da los, meine Binaries sind, keine Ahnung, 500 Kilobyte
oder so, aber juckt halt heutzutage nicht mehr, ja und ich nutze das für alles mögliche,
also wir haben einige Eigenentwicklungen von mir am Start mittlerweile für die unterschiedlichsten
Sachen und dann, nachdem ich halt nun mal unter anderem es mit meinem Job ist, so für
ordentliche, wie nennt man das, Tools und Automatisierung zu sorgen, mache ich damit
relativ viel, ja das stimmt schon, wir haben, also wir haben diese, nun mal so als Beispiel,
so ganz unterschiedliche Sachen, die wir am Start haben, wir haben diese Squid-Lock-Auswertung,
ich habe einen Spam, ferngesteuerten Browser, der Spam frei gibt, gebastelt, weil unser
Spam-Anbieter sackt, unser Spam-Anbieter hat keine API, also wir haben einen E-Mail-Anbieter,
der macht für uns Spam-Filter von E-Mails und die haben keine API um Spam frei zu geben,
das einzige was man machen kann ist einen Browser fernsteuern und sich im Web-Interface bei
denen einloggen und automatisch quasi dann die Maske durchklicken für E-Mails aus dem
Spam-Folder freigeben, richtig hängen geblieben, Moment die Lautstärke stimmt heute, warte
mal, die Lautstärke muss auf 48 und die Mario Kart Musik muss leiser, so ist gut, weil dass
man das auch hört, kann ja nicht sein, dass man ihn nicht hört, was ist da unten, ah
ich hab vergessen den hier auszublenden, was haben wir denn sonst noch so alles, das Spam-Aufräum-Tool,
das Squid-Aufräum-Durchsuch-Programm, boah wir haben so 5-6 Sachen, lass mal überlegen,
das sind aber die wo ich am häufigsten dran rum basteln muss, ja wir haben jede Menge
Confluence-Importe, das ist so ein Atlassian-Wiki-System, wir haben jede Menge Confluence-Importe von
automatisch generierten Inhalten, die ich über die Confluence-API reinpumpe, übrigens
Frage an euch, Chat, Frage an euch, Chat, verwendet ihr, beziehungsweise verwendet ihr
auf der Arbeit, also egal ob ihr euch jetzt privat aufstellt, auf der Arbeit, aber auf
der Arbeit müsst ihr mal interessieren, verwendet ihr das Atlassian Cloud gehostete Confluence
und Jira, verwendet ihr den Kram jemand bei euch, die Sache ist nämlich die, wir haben
jetzt unser, seit ungefähr 2 Wochen oder so, wurde unser Jira und Confluence umgezogen
auf die Atlassian Cloud und seitdem ist das bestimmt, ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben,
bei uns war es die ganze Zeit auch gehostet, aber selbst gehostet sagt man ja nicht mehr
und lokal sagt man auch, die coole Leute sagen ja On-Premise oder On-Prem, habe ich ja ganz
vergessen, aber bei uns war das auch lokal gehostet und jetzt hat man das in die Cloud
gegeben, weil die das angeblich viel besser können, würde mir auch vorausgehen, dass
Atlassian das besser kann, das ist ja immer ihre eigene Software und das Problem ist
jetzt, ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben, aber mir kommt so vor als Ruckel, dass mindestens
2 mal am Tag, also es hat mindestens 2 mal am Tag längere Ruckler von 30 Sekunden bis
5 Minuten und ich meine, das kann doch nicht sein, beim offiziellen Hersteller der Software
und bei der offiziellen Cloud von denen, was machen die denn, also da weiß ich, ob der
Schall einen von euch mit Erfahrung gemacht hat, also ich finde das ganz grausam.
Captain ZK, Dankeschön, für den Sub und danach kommt CDFEDC, ist das irgendein Hex,
Hex für irgendwas, CDFEDC, ist das irgendein Hex, was, was mir was sagen müsste oder was
für Needspeak das, Imagine Arbeit, Cringe, wer arbeitet richtig Cringe, die Erfahrung
hast du auch mit der Atlassian Cloud gemacht, ah das beruhigt mich, dass ich da nicht allein
bin, der das Kacke findet, hatte einen Generator für meine Ausbildungsberichte geschrieben,
der mir aus Asher alle meine Comments sortiert und deine Comments messages waren so gut,
dass man daraus Ausbildungsberichte generieren kann, ich glaube jetzt erzählst du uns was
hier, das, das glaube ich dir nicht, der SAP Entwickler beziehungsweise SAP Berater ist
irgendwie so ne ganz eigene Spezies, ja das stimmt, das kommt ja auch noch dazu, ab 2025
oder irgendwie so gibt es doch nur noch Cloud, ja das stimmt, ich hab ganz vergessen, wobei
ich nicht verstehe, was diese für ne bescheuerte Entscheidung ist, ja ich glaube ab 2025 oder
so was, ja so siehts bei mir auch aus, also meine privaten Repos sehen ungefähr so aus,
init, das nächste Comet ist dann CacW, das nächste Comet ist Lul oder das nächste Comet
ist POC oder sonst was, irgendwelche random Emotes und auf der Arbeit mach ichs meistens
so, ich bin mega faul was das angeht, ich hab heute was comitted, das ist eigentlich
total bescheuert, das darfst eigentlich keinem erzählen, ich hab reingeschrieben, also ich
hab keine Ahnung wann irgendwie 3-4 Dateien angepasst oder so und wir haben nen Change
Log, da steht dann immer so ganz grob drinnen, also das ist quasi ne Zusammenfassung, so
ne, so ne, so ne, too long didn't read Zusammenfassung aus den ganzen Comets, dass man so innerhalb
mal einmal im Monat gucken kann, was ist denn jetzt so zwischen den unterschiedlichen Versionen
passiert und ich hab 3-4 Dateien geändert und ich hab im Change Log was eingetragen
und dann hab ich nen Comet gemacht, update Change Log, scheiß auf die andere 3 Dateien
und die Änderung, update Change Log, ich hatte die Auswahl, mach ich da jetzt 3 Comets
raus oder 2 Comets oder sonst was, was haste denn als letztes gemacht, ah Change Log geupdatet,
update Change Log, stört kein, stört kein, weil wenn es einen stören müsste, dann mich,
weil ich mir das eigentlich angucke, was da so reinkommt und mich stört es nicht, weil
ich es selbst gemacht hab, weil ich es selbst gemacht hab, trotzdem praktisch nach 2 jahre
keine Berichte schreibe, oh ja, ich hab auch keine Ausbildungsberichte geschrieben und
bei der Prüfung haben sie gesagt, wenn meine Ausbildungen, also wenn es jetzt auf die Ausbildungsberichte
angekommen wäre, wäre ich durchgefallen, weil die waren richtig schlecht, die waren
auch randomized, mit eingescanter Unterschrift von irgendeinem Kollege auf der Arbeit, der
also nicht einfach so von mir eingescannt, ne, muss ich sagen, nichts Illegales, der
hat gesagt, Max, scan meine Unterschrift ein und mach die drunter, ich hab die nicht einfach
gerippt irgendwo von irgendeinem Zettel, die Unterschrift oder so, da muss ich schon bescheiden,
ja und danach, danach gleich den neuen Digitalführerschein gemacht, hoffe ich mal, oh, rip, danach gleich
den neuen Digitalführerschein, ich muss mich leider in der Ausbildung mit Sharepoint befassen,
Painschamp, Painschamp, Sharepoint, naja, man könnte einfach sagen, git commit minus minus
allow empty, da kannst du auch leere Commits machen, also wenn du es drauf anlegst, dann,
ah gut, es sei denn, ihr habt irgendeinen Hook, der das blockt, also wenn du es drauf
anlegst, kannst du auch leere Commits machen, letzten Commits sind final, final, final, last
final, ultimative final, die meisten Leute scheinen aber nicht zu wissen, ich seh das
bei uns auch witzigerweise öfters, dass dann da steht, so nach dem Motto Feature XY und
danach kommt fix, fix, fix, fix, fix, fix, fix, dann sag ich dir, Leute, ihr könnt das,
wenn ihr das nicht rebasen wollt oder so, Schwachsinn, wenn ihr das nicht interactive
rebasen wollt, ihr könnt einfach resetten und ein neues Commit machen, dann passt ihr
das alles zu einem zusammen, also man braucht keine Pullrequests zu machen mit 20 fix Commits
oder sowas drin, wie, wir haben keinen, warum haben wir nicht mehr Monka Christ als Emote,
Christ, Christ, Monka Christ, cringe, wenn man keine gescheiten Emotes hat, Dumboy, danke
für den Sub, nein, nein, nein, also die richtige, die richtige Variante ist, Git Commit, minus,
minus allow empty, minus, minus amend, minus a und am besten noch Groß a, wobei war das
nicht, das war bei Git add mit dem Groß a, auch noch alle unbekannte Dateien anhängen
am letzten Commit und einfach immer nur ein Commit verwenden und dann danach selbstverständlich
Force pushen, so machen das die Profis, dann hat man, dann hat man richtig schönes, sauberes
Git Repo, was immer nur ein Commit enthält mit dem aktuellsten Stand, das ist genau richtig
für die Leute, die auch keine Dokumentation und Tests für ihre Software schreiben, weil,
wir wissen ja alle, man braucht das nicht, man muss einfach nur fehlerfrei programmieren
und der Code muss selbsterklärend sein, dann braucht man keine Tests und keine Dokumentation
und dementsprechend braucht man auch keine Git Commit, irgendwie eine ordentliche History,
dass das nacheinander aufbaut, einfach ein Commit, fertig, lean Git History, du hast
für ScarePoint, ich finde ja die Umschreibung von mancher Software gut, ScarePoint habe
ich noch nicht gehört, was ich öfter schon gehört habe ist Shit Tricks, was ich ja
persönlich gut finde, Shit Tricks und Shit Tricks trifft es ja auch wirklich ganz gut,
was mir immer auf den Sack geht, wenn Leute was pushen, ohne vorher einen Pull zu machen,
dann ewig lange Merchzeuge, ja das nervt mich auch, ich hasse Commits, wo drin steht, Merch
Master in Master, das sind irgendwelche Noobs, also da siehst du gleich, dass das Noobs
ist, entweder macht man, übrigens nur mal so als Tipp, ich weiß ja nicht, du kannst
sagen, du bist der Ultra Profi, vielleicht weißt du das auch, aber nur so als Tipp,
weil ich weiß, dass es bei uns viele nicht wissen, wenn man vergessen hat zu Pullen,
bevor man Committed, gibt es eine ganz einfache Variante, man macht einfach das Commit und
dann sagt man Git Pull minus minus Rebase und was das dann macht ist, das geht zurück
auf den letzten Stand, von dem zwischen deinem Branch und dem Remote Branch, wo die gleich
waren, pullt dann und dann cherrypickst obendrauf dein Commit, Git Pull minus minus Rebase,
ist wunderbar, wenn man solche Merch Master in Master vermeiden will, alternativ kann
man auch gleich rebasen, wie auch immer, wir haben eh viele Leute, Leute ich hatte heute
wieder Begegnungen der abenteuerlichen Art, also jetzt nicht Gatchibust abenteuerliche
Art, also mit einem Entwickler und zwar, wir sollten einen Reverse Proxy vor einen internen
Server stellen, damit der jetzt HTTPS, also TLS, SSL macht, weil denn Service selbst,
der ist so alt und ich versuche das mal zu zitieren, sinngemäß hat er sowas gesagt,
wie die Leute, die wissen, wie dieser Service funktioniert, sind gestorben oder haben gekündigt,
also es hat keiner mehr Ahnung, wie der Kram funktioniert, so und da hat er gesagt, daran
programmieren wir nichts mehr um, könnt ihr uns nicht einen Reverse Proxy wegen SSL davor
machen, habe ich gemacht, ich habe einfach einen Karte downloadet, drauf geschoben,
selbst sein Zertifikat und gut ist und ich habe das denen auch gesagt, das ist ein selbst
sein Zertifikat, dann haben die gesagt, ach es ist kein Problem, können wir ignorieren,
können wir trusten, wie auch immer, selbst sein Zertifikat, kein Problem und heute kriege
ich eine Message vom Entwickler, mein Kleiner vertraut dem Zertifikat nicht.
Da dachte ich mir so, was, nein, no shit, damit hätten wir jetzt echt nicht rechnen
können und da meinte er, kannst du mir das Zertifikat schicken, damit ich dem trusten
kann, äh, du brauchst mein Zertifikat nicht, dass du dem trusten kannst, du gehst einfach
mit deinem Browser auf die Seite und da kannst du dir noch die ganzen Zertifikatsachen angucken,
die runterladen willst, meinetwegen, da ladest du die aus dem Browser runter, aber ich muss
dir doch jetzt nicht irgendwie Zertifikat schicken, das haben sie mich gebacken bekommen,
zumal ich ihm auch extra gesagt habe, das wird eh nicht funktionieren, ich habe ihm
extra gesagt, er muss der CA trusten und nicht dem Zertifikat, weil wenn er der CA trustet,
dann hat er für 11 Jahre ausgesorgt, wenn er dem Zertifikat trustet, muss er jeden Tag
neu trusten, oh man, ja, ist bei uns auch so, wir haben externe Experten, ähm, die bei
uns Sachen machen und unter anderem halt auch mal, ähm, Configs und Automatisierungs-Sachen
und sonstigen Kram in irgendwelche Gitrepos committen und die tun sich damit so schwer
und ich denke mir halt, Leute, wenn ich Experte bin bzw. wenn ich Externer bin, der quasi
mit seinen Skills soweit überzeugen muss, dass die Leute ihm Geld dafür geben, ähm,
und ihn auch behalten, warum lernt man das nicht einfach mal so in den, so die Basics
machen, da muss er nicht gleich auf den Mount Everest, das reicht ja, wenn man die Basics
macht, wenn man so die 5, 6, 7, ja, notwendigsten Operationen mit Shit kann, das reicht doch
schon, das verstehe ich auch nicht und wir haben den Externen bei uns, den finde ich
ganz schlimm, in einem Punkt, nämlich, wenn du zu dem sagst, ja, ähm, wie sieht es denn
da und da aus, dann sagt er, ja, äh, ja, wie machen wir das denn jetzt am besten, wo
ist das denn dokumentiert, das ist seine Standardantwort, er fragt auf alles und jeden, wo ist das denn
dokumentiert, mittlerweile frage ich ihn immer als Antwort, ja, du machst das doch jetzt
schon das fünfte Mal, warum hast du es denn jetzt mit dem Teil immer aufgeschrieben,
weil das sind, ich frag mich immer, was ist mit den Externen, Experten los, sollten die
nicht eigentlich Ahnung haben, irgendwie ist das, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht kriegen
wir auch einfach nur, vielleicht sind wir zu geizig mit dem Geld oder haben zu schlechte
Arbeitsbedingungen oder sonst was, vielleicht kriegen wir keine guten Experten, keine Ahnung,
wobei wir durchaus, wobei wir haben durchaus gute Leute, ja, das ist, so ist es nicht,
wir haben manche Spezialisten, da frage ich mich echt, also, ja, gut, ähm, geht es eh
immer bewertet, ja, brauchen wir nicht, einfach Copy Paste von Ordnern, Old, Older, New Change,
einfach neue Ordner anlegen und jedes Mal kopieren, meine aktuelle Abteilung, mache
duale Studium, Elektrotechnik, wechsel deswegen immer, benutzt noch kein Git, was benutzen
die denn, naja, gut, ist doch egal, ob die, ähm, irgendwelche Schaltungsgedüns entwickeln
oder sonst was, überall, wo Textfiles anfallen und versioniert werden müssen, ist das eigentlich
sinnvoll, es ist ja, ist ja eigentlich zweitrangig, ob das jetzt T++ Zeug ist oder irgendwelche
anderen Plain Text Kram, der sich quasi in Zusammenarbeit mit mehreren Leuten weiter
entwickelt, also ich finde das eigentlich praktisch, bei dem Monorepo Trend ist Git
ja auch überbewertet, das eine hat mit dem anderen noch gar nichts zu tun, Monorepo heißt
doch einfach nur, man macht keine 20, also von der Idee her, heißt ja einfach nur, man
macht keine 20 Repos mehr, was weiß ich, man hat irgendein Projekt und hat da nicht
den Pasa in einem eigenen Repo, das Frontend in einem eigenen Repo, das Backend in einem
eigenen Repo, sondern hat dann quasi ein Repo mit mehreren Unterordnungen, übrigens
Monorepo, soll ich euch mal Monorepo zeigen, guckt euch mal an, Repos, der Monchamp, Monorepo,
Backend und Frontend, Leute, Check, voll am Puls der Zeit, voll am Puls der Zeit, also
da sind die Trends hier, da kannst du uns nicht mehr mit schocken, Monorepo, ja, Backend
und Frontend zusammen in einem Git, Clear Case, das kenne ich nicht, Stereo Repo, ja
in dem Fall ist es tatsächlich Stereo, noch, noch Stereo Repo, Agil Witz nicht mehr, ne,
ist vorbei, was brauchst du als Backend, das ist wie immer bei mir, wenn ich Web Anwendungszeug
mache, ASP.NET, Core, nicht ASP.NET, uralt, so, ja, danke für den Sub, Noor, Loves Pancakes,
Fock, ja, wir haben so viele Leute, die angeblich Experten sind und keine Ahnung haben, es ist
echt immer wieder abenteuerlich und erstaunlich, ja, USB Sticks größer Git, weißt du was,
soll ich dir mal sagen, man kann Git Repos auf USB Sticks kopieren, ist das, ist das
dann besser, das ist keine exklusiven Technologien, Excel anstatt Git, ja das sehe ich ein, ja,
eindeutig, Excel Version Control, was ist deine Meinung zu Low Code, da kann ich tatsächlich
was zu sagen, wir haben nämlich eine Low Code Plattform bei uns auf der Arbeit jetzt und
damit versucht die, irgendwelche Buchhaltungsgeschichten, also wer das nicht kennt, das beste Beispiel
für Low Code ist, Battlefield 2042 Portal Logic Editor, das hier, das hier ist Low Code,
so grafische Programmiertools ist damit gemacht, oder was ja nicht zwangsläufig, was genau
so aussieht, aber was in der Richtung, das ist quasi für Leute, die nicht programmieren
können, dass sie doch irgendwas programmieren können, so und wir haben irgendwas bei uns
im Einsatz, ich weiß nicht, ob es, was sagt jemand, ist es Power Apps, keine Ahnung, ich
habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was es für eine Plattform ist, weiß ich nicht, ich
weiß nur, dass wir irgendeine Plattform testweise im Einsatz haben und dort soll, irgendeine
Mischung glaube ich aus Buchhaltung und Personalabteilung und so was, die sollen da irgendwas drinne
zusammenklicken und was programmieren und die kriegen es auch nicht wirklich gebacken.
ja beste Hacker, Angriffsziel ja, weshalb hast du die Konsole so dunkel, du
meinst das hier, warum nicht, ja weil ich nicht geflashbanked werden will wie hier vom
Browser, das kann man auch machen und soll ich euch mal was sagen, jetzt wird es richtig
advanced IQ, du kannst USB Inhalte in ein Git Repo hauen und das Git Repo anschließend
wieder auf den USB Stick, wir haben unendlichen Speicherplatz erfunden gerade, hast du eine
Ahnung, wie man in ASP.NET eine CraftQL API macht, bei der man sich mit Active Directory
SSO autentifizieren kann und die Rechte über irgendwelche Addictive Policies sagen, ganz
ehrlich, wie man eine CraftQL API macht, das weiß ich, das habe ich schon oft genug gemacht,
Active Directory SSO habe ich noch nie gemacht, aber in der Regel machst du es ja bei CraftQL
mit irgendwelchen Tokens, das müsste ich mir angucken, also ich denke das würde ich
schon hinkriegen, aber ich kann es dir aus dem Kopf nicht sagen, das habe ich noch nie
gemacht, keine Ahnung, funktioniert das gescheit, weil die Sache ist die, Git hat ja manchmal
wenn du was machst, so Log Files und wenn du die syncst, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob
das gescheit funktioniert, Git Repo auf einem Dropbox oder Next Cloud Share, gut, wenn man
alleine dran arbeitet, wahrscheinlich, gute Frage, dazu habe ich noch nie Gedanken gemacht,
Leute wir wollten heute eigentlich was Programmierstelles machen, aber ich komme dem Chatcard nicht
nach, klingt nach Power, wie gesagt ich weiß nicht wie es heißt, ist Tailwind nicht eigentlich
auch Low Code, nee, Tailwind ist ja im Prinzip quasi vorgefertigt CSS Klassen, CSS ist Styling,
das ist gar kein Code im eigentlichen Sinne, wie gesagt mit Low Codes ist es so wie Blockly
oder sowas gemeint, ich überlege gerade ob ich überhaupt einen Account bei AWS habe,
also ich habe privat schon mal vereinzelt Sachen bei Google gemacht, Cloud Technik und
hauptsächlich mache ich Sachen in Azure, weil wir eben auf der Arbeit sehr viel Azure
verwenden, Azure zum Azuren, was ist denn CraftQL, wie kann man das jetzt mal kurzzeitig
erklären, das ist quasi, anstatt dass du normale HTTP, Git, Pull, Delete, sonst was Restrequest
machst, hast du einen Endpoint über den du genau mit einer Abfragesprache definieren
kannst was du haben willst, also du hast quasi schon eine eingebaute Query Language wenn
du es so willst, du kannst filtern, du kannst sortieren, du kannst sagen welche Felder du
zurück haben willst, also du kannst beispielsweise sagen, ich will alle User, aber mich interessiert
bei den Usern nur der Vorname und die ID, alles andere interessiert mich nicht und dann
kannst du noch suchen oder sortieren lassen oder sowas, also das ist für solche Sachen
dann tatsächlich ganz praktisch, ist aber nicht für alles sinnvoll, also wie gesagt
normale HTTP Requests, was weiß ich, User hat Button gedrückt, dann musst du nicht
über CraftQL API machen, wozu, und wo CraftQL auch wirklich sehr nice ist, es sind Subscriptions,
weil das Ding unterstützt Websocket Verbindung unter der Haube, da kannst du quasi dich
benachrichtigen lassen, wenn sich auf dem Server an deinem Datenbestand was ändert,
haben wir übrigens hier in unserer Anwendung, wo wir heute dran rumbauen wollen, auch drinne,
weiter dran bauen wollen, du würdest das gerne brauchen für ein Projekt, ja da müssen wir
mal gucken, also wie gesagt, ich habe es noch nie gemacht, wir könnten uns da ein bisschen
mit beschäftigen, CraftQL APN Punkt mit SSO Active Directory, da bräuchten wir nur irgendeine
Testumgebung irgendwie, wo wir das ausprobieren können, also das würden wir aber auf jeden
Fall rauskriegen, wie das funktioniert, beziehungsweise wenn es nicht direkt funktioniert, wie man
das am besten macht, ich kenne mich halt bis zu dem Punkt aus CraftQL API, Active Directory
Alternifizierung, keine Ahnung, was, Daten brauchen doch eine gewisse Zeit durch ein
Kabel, sprich, können Kabel so Sachen speichern, zumindest für den Bruchteil einer Sekunde,
naja, die Sache ist die, damit du sinnvolle Daten übertragen kannst, besteht das aus
ganz schön vielen kleinen Signalen auf der Leitung, also auf die Leitung drauf, modul
encodete Signale, wo dann irgendwann wieder ein Netzwerkpaket rausfällt und aus dem Netzwerkpaket
sehr, also in dem Ethernet Frame ist ein Netz, ist ein TCP Package drinne, da drinne ist
dann, ist ein IP Package drinne, da drinne ist ein TCP, da drinne ist dann irgendwie
HTTP oder sonst was, also sprich, damit du die Daten überhaupt sinnvoll übertragen
kannst, hast du ja ganz viele Kontrollsachen drum herum, wo alle Seiten sich im Vorfeld
aber auch im Klaren sein müssen, wie man das interpretieren muss, so und das heißt,
wenn du jetzt da drinne im Kabel, sagen wir mal, 3 Bits gespeichert hast oder so, dann
bringt dir das nicht viel, weil du ja keine Rückschlüsse drauf ziehen kannst, also was
das denn eigentlich mal sein soll oder werden soll, also dass, selbst wenn du ein Kabel bis
zum Mond hättest, also, das kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, dass du im
Kabel was langfristig speichern kannst, zumal du ja auch Widerstand im Kabel hast und du
brauchst dich ja, du kommst ja gar nicht bis zum Mond damit, so, Bernd Blu, danke für
den Sub, also für sowas, für sowas ist tatsächlich CraftQL ziemlich nice, ein Entry Point und
dann verschiedene Sachen abfangen, also dafür ist CraftQL wirklich gut, ich kann euch mal
ein CraftQL Beispiel zeigen, so, wir haben hier unsere Fake Monitor Anwendung vom letzten
Mal, ich geh mal auf die CraftQL Übungsseite davon, äh 5000 nicht 3000, so, guck mal,
so, hier kannst du jetzt Sachen abfragen, also ein riesen Vorteil von CraftQL ist, du
hast nen Schema, das heißt, du weißt, wie deine Daten auf Serverseite aussehen, dementsprechend
kannst du auch zumindest so, ähm, so Tools ganz gut bauen mit Autocomplete, so, ich kann
jetzt sagen, ok, ich möchte vom Server benachrichtigt werden über jede Änderung an meiner Alert
Collection auf dem Server, aber von den Alerts interessiert mich nur der Name, wenn ich jetzt
die Subscription abschicke, krieg ich alle Alerts und jeden weiteren Alert und nur den
Name, ich kann aber auch sagen, ok, mich interessiert nicht nur der Name, mich interessiert auch
noch die ID, also ich kann mit CraftQL genau das abfragen, was ich will, ohne, dass ich
meine Leitungen vollmüllen muss, mit started at source, severity, environment und sonst
noch was, so, das ist die aller einfachste Variante von CraftQL, Queries, das wird schon,
das wird noch besser, wenn die Typen nestet sind, ja, es könnte ja zum Beispiel sein,
dass Name kein einfacher String ist, sondern ein Objekt, dann könnte ich dann jetzt hier
noch sagen, keine Ahnung, nur last name oder sowas, also, man kann das beliebig nesten
und je nachdem, was man für den CraftQL Server hat, man kann das wunderbar auch sortieren,
da kann man dann angeben, ob man das aufsteigen, absteigen kann, man kann filtern, man könnte
dann zum Beispiel sowas sagen, da bin ich mir jetzt allerdings gerade für die Syntax
nicht sicher, ich könnte sowas sagen, irgendwie, was weiß ich, filter, da weiß ich wirklich,
wie gesagt, die Syntax aus dem Kopf nicht, da könnte ich sowas sagen, wie filter, name,
equals, keqw, oder sowas, also, ich könnte schon direkt filtern, von Anfang an und ich
kann paginateen, paginateen, wie auch immer man das nennt, halt die Daten quasi in Stückchen
hacken lassen vom Server, dass ich sagen kann, ok, erste Seite 20 Stück, zweite Seite
20 Stück, dritte Seite nur noch 5 Stück, weil die Daten aufgebraucht sind, also spätestens
für das Suchen, für das Suchen, Filtern und Sortieren, bräuchte ich, bräuchte ich bei
einem Rest End Punkt jede Menge extra Query Options, die ich selbst implementieren muss
und die meisten CraftQL Server können das von Haus aus und das ist auch in den Clients
eingebaut, das heißt, das spart da schon einiges an Gefrickel.
So, du kannst die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, so, genau, ich habe dann stehen geblieben.
Wie ist deine Erfahrung mit Sven, lohnt es sich, sich damit zu beschäftigen?
Ich finde das richtig nice, aber es ist eher was, wo man sich mal angucken kann, weil es
einen interessiert, also wenn man was verbreitetes haben will oder gar versucht damit Geld zu
verdienen, dann sind die anderen Frameworks aktuell noch besser, also mit anderen Frameworks
ist im Endeffekt mein React ganz vorne Nummer 1, Vue und Angular, Angular ist halt im Business
Enterprise Umfeld recht beliebt, wobei ich persönlich mit Angular nie richtig warm geworden
bin, von React habe ich auch keine große Ahnung, ich kenne mich mit Vue ganz gut aus und das
Welt hat mich vom Ansatz her interessiert, also ja, ich finde das sehr nice, es ist auch
cool, was man damit machen kann, aber eben sagen, man muss aber mal ehrlich sagen, viele
Sachen sind ähnlich zwischen den Frameworks, ja, wie man Data Binding macht und sowas,
das ist jetzt busy andere Sündtags, aber so der riesen Unterschied ist es nicht, also
mit Vue fährst du deutlich besser als mit Svelte, wenn du das irgendwie im professionellen
Umfeld einsetzen willst, aktuell noch, Svelte war ein paar Jahre zu spät, wären die 4-5
Jahre früher gewesen, wenn die Welt heute alles voll ausfällt, genau, eine Session mit
Azure wäre, wir haben sogar vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal ein Azure Stream gemacht,
allerdings Microsoft hat meine 100 Euro Guthaben gesperrt, was ist wirklich nicht gesperrt,
das ist ein Problem, das hatte ich noch nicht, es ist ja nicht so, als wäre ich irgendwie
hauptberuflicher Webentwickler, der den ganzen Tag CraftQL macht oder so, das Problem hatte
ich ehrlich gesagt noch nicht und wir werden das Problem auch nicht bekommen, weil wir
ja prinzipiell keine Fehler machen, deswegen brauchen wir auch keine Dokumentation und
keine Tests und dementsprechend müssen wir uns auch nicht um Error Handling kümmern
in CraftQL, ne, aber keine Ahnung, so, Pasi, Dankeschön für den Sub, ich habe bestimmt
wieder die Hälfte übersehen, hier, ja, Blue auch am Start, Pog, so, wir machen mal weiter,
also, wo haben wir das letzte Mal aufgehört, wir haben so ein Fake Monitoring System gebaut,
was Fake Monitoring Meldungen in CraftQL zurückgibt, ja, zum Beispiel, dass die CPU Usage auf mail.altea.org
viel zu hoch ist, das geht nicht und Olga, die AI von Olga, die AI von Olga, die war
dauernd und die Memory Usage auf Blockchain Leslie ist viel zu hoch und ihr seht schon,
das Frontend aktualisiert sich von alleine, weil das über CraftQL Subscriptions geht,
mein Server ist, ich sollte das vielleicht mal öffnen, fällt mir gerade auf, ich habe
noch weder, ich habe kein Editor oder sonst was auf, Lul, kurz, ja, ja, ich truste, ich
truste alles, kurz, Zeug aufmachen, wir bauen weiter am Fake Monitoring Tool, korrekt, ja,
ich, ich zeige euch das gleich nochmal, ich muss gerade mal das öffnen, weil ich habe
ein bisschen was umgebaut, noch Offstream, ich habe das alles ein bisschen ordentlicher
gemacht, dass es nicht so Kraut und Rüben war wie im Stream, der Mondchamp, da ist er,
Mondchamp Backend, also, der CraftQL Server bzw. das Backend, das könnte nicht viel
einfacher sein, so, das könnte im Prinzip nicht viel einfacher sein, also ich habe,
das ist alles übrigens, 103 Zeilen, das ist unser komplettes Backend, also das macht nichts
großartiges, das erlaubt Anfragen von überall, der Start an den CraftQL Server hat eine Klasse
für die Alerts, irgendwo müssen wir die Daten ja speichern, die wir hier anzeigen, und dann
hat es nur eine Klasse für CraftQL Subscriptions, felby, danke für den Sub, fällt dir mal ein
Use Case ein, wo ein untrusted Workspace schädlich wäre, ich weiß nicht, was, was, was, was
Visual Studio Code irgendwie nachlädt oder so aus einem Workspace, keine Ahnung, so und
dann generieren wir ganz viele random Fake Daten, Environment Messages, Error Level,
Hostnamen und geben 500 Error Messages zurück an Browser, so, das ist, das ist alles, mehr
macht das Backend nicht, und worauf wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich, wo bin ich denn
stehen geblieben, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich, weshalb habe ich euch das jetzt
nochmal gezeigt, ich wollte es doch irgendwie, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht, so, und heute,
und heute bauen wir da dran weiter, ich überlege gerade mit was wir anfangen, was das müssten
die Files sein, halt wie, welche Files, so, ja ihr seht es aktualisiert sich automatisch,
weil alle 30 Sekunden werden neue 500 Fehlermeldungen generiert, also das hier ist wirklich sehr,
sagen wir mal, übersichtlich alles, ich glaube, das kann man jetzt mehr oder weniger auf einen
Blick halbwegs nachvollziehen, glaube ich noch, wenn nicht, könnt ihr mich natürlich
fragen, aber das hier ist eigentlich das Wichtige, das ist eine Endlosschleife, die alle 30 Sekunden
neue Fake-Monitoring-Meldungen generiert, und warum mache ich das Ganze, das hat zwei Gründe,
Leute, ich muss mal auf irgendeine Seite mit Dark Mode gehen, sonst werde ich immer geflashbankt,
wenn ich hier aus Versehen auf den Browser switche, ja, Roblox, sehr schön, ja wofür
habe ich das Ganze gemacht, ganz einfach, zum Üben, das ist alles zum Üben, und ich möchte,
oder ich habe angefangen, da auch was Sinnvolles draus zu bauen, nämlich, wir haben auf der
Arbeit, steht auch dann Firefox auf Dark Mode, habe ich, ich habe hier den Dark Reader drauf,
der macht die Seiten auch so schon dunkel, wenn es nicht dunkel ist, ich habe für die
Welt was ähnliches gebaut, und zwar, wir haben auf der Arbeit Prometheus zum größten Teil,
nicht alleine, wir haben Prometheus fürs Monitoring, wo unser Support, also ich nenne es mal Support,
wir haben so einen 24-7, wie nennt man das, Control-Observierungs-Center oder sowas, weiß
gar nicht, wie die offiziell heißen bei uns, die sind 24-7 da, und gucken, ob es Störungen
gibt, und eskalieren dann die Störungen weiter, also im Schichtbetrieb mit Nachtschicht und
allem, so, und wir haben halt ziemlich viele Systeme, sowohl offline, als auch in der Cloud,
und wir haben Millionen an Prometheus-Daten, die rumfliegen, das ist wirklich teilweise
kaum noch überschaubar, und wo die nen Problem haben ist, so ne ganz klassische Ansicht zu
haben, wann ist wo was kaputt gegangen, und man kann sowas im Krafana bauen, aber das
ist nicht, also Krafana ist nicht für so ne tabellarische Darstellung gedacht, Krafana
und generell Prometheus ist ja dafür gedacht, Metriken zu sammeln, also sprich, dass man
zum Beispiel in seine Anwendung einbaut, dass die Anwendung regelmäßig exportiert, wie
viele Garbage-Collector-Runs hat es gehabt, wie sind die Threads ausgelastet, wie sieht
es mit dem Threadpool aus, irgendwelche internen Anwendungsmetriken, dafür ist ja Prometheus
eigentlich gedacht, und auch Krafana fürs Darstellen von sowas, und so ne klassische
Übersicht, wann wie wo was kaputt gegangen ist, oder beziehungsweise einfach, stell euch
das auf ne Monitoring Wand vor, stellt euch das auf ne Monitoring Wand vor, da sitzen
Leute davor, und die Monitoring Wand ist leer, und auf einmal geht was kaputt, und es ploppen
drei Sachen auf, dann ist das hier relativ schnell zu sehen, wann das war, und was da
so ne Fehlermeldung gekommen ist, wohingegen du das im Prometheus in irgendeinem Metrik-Graf
im Krafana nicht so schön siehst, natürlich bekommen die auch irgendeine Alert-Mail,
oder irgendein Alert-Ticket automatisch, aber so ne einfache Übersicht, das fehlt, und
da bin ich grad dabei sowas zu basteln.
Das war übrigens auch das Stein des Anstoßes, warum ich gesagt hab, ich probier das hier
mal im Stream aus, sowas zu bauen, natürlich würd ich da nicht sagen, dass Backup auf
Tyler.org kaputt ist, dafür gibt's den Alert-Manager, der Alert-Manager suckt für so ne Übersicht,
du hast im Alert-Manager nicht so ne Übersicht in dieser Richtung, Alert-Manager, ja wir
haben auch einen Alert-Manager, aber der Alert-Manager ist, ähm, Demo, aber irgendwie ne schöne,
Demo, die haben glaub ich schon ne Demo, Demo, Demo, Robust Perception IO, alles klar, so,
im Alert-Manager hast du sowas, ganz ehrlich, damit können vielleicht die super Eingeweihten,
die diese Checks angelegt haben, was anfangen, aber wenn ne Meldung kommt, dass, keine Ahnung,
ähm, ja, das ist ja noch relativ aussagekräftig eigentlich, normalerweise steht da mehr, ja
das ist nicht so, ne, also wenn dann irgendwo ne Meldung reinkommt, dass, äh, Job gleich
Kubernetes XYZ failed ist, äh, und 50 Labels, da kann dort keiner was mit anfangen, es gibt
die Möglichkeit, dass man das ordentlich Custom taggt, aber dann hast du wieder die Sache,
wo zeigst du diese Custom Tags an, es gibt, es gibt ein schönes Beispiel für, ich weiß
nicht, ob ihr dieses Karma, ob jemand von euch dieses Karma Dashboard kennt, das ist
ja auch so ein Prometheus-Frontend, was versucht, das ein bisschen hübscher aufzubereiten,
und jetzt guckt euch mal diese Datenflut an, jetzt mal seriously.
Gibt es jemand, der da raus auf die Schnelle erkennt, was wie wo kaputt ist?
Also das mag zwar schön sein, aber das ist gnadenloser Informationsoverload, ja, das
ist ja auch so ne Art Knock-Blue-Media, genau sowas ist das in der Richtung, Leitstand trifft
es eigentlich ganz gut, genau sowas ist das, dafür sind die da, die gucken auf ne Monitoring-Wand
und rufen dann jemand an, und die haben halt wirklich Probleme, das zu erkennen aus diesen
Alert-Manager-Meldungen, der Alert-Manager macht bei uns zwar Tickets auf, die Sache
ist die, du kannst aber nicht automatisch sagen, Erstellzeitpunkt des Tickets wäre
gleich, Beginn eines Fehlers, weil da könnt du, ich gerade durch Jira Cloud gelegge, bis
zu, wir hatten letztens, das hat sogar richtig Probleme gemacht, letztens ist bei uns ein
Reverse-Programm bzw. das Loadbalancer abgekackt, und das Ticket, dass der Loadbalancer abgekackt
ist, kam 15 Minuten, also 16 Minuten, ich sag mal 15 Minuten, nachdem das abgekackt
ist, und so ein Loadbalancer ist kacke, weil wenn ein Loadbalancer abkackt, dann ist es
nicht so wie bei einem Service dahinter, dass es abgefangen werden kann, wenn der falsche
Loadbalancer abkackt, dann ist auch wirklich was kaputt, und wenn man das erst 15 Minuten
später merkt, ist doof, wahrscheinlich hat Jira in der Cloud gerade wieder geruckelt
oder sowas, zumindest das war der Stein des Anstoßes, dass ich mir gedacht hab, man könnte
doch so eine ganz simple Übersicht basteln und die Alert-Manager-RP verwenden, um so
eine Oldschool-Nagios-Style Übersicht zu machen, vor 10 Minuten ist das hier kaputt
gegangen auf diesem Server, und mehr nicht, und das kann man dann auf eine Monitoring-Wand
machen, und dann ist gut, und dann sieht man sofort, was Sache ist, das muss gar nicht
super komplex sein, genau Plumedia, sowas in der Richtung, ähm, übrigens, ich hab das
umbenannt, letztes, letzten Stream hieß das ganze noch Monchamp, ich hab's umgenannt
in MTSM, wisst ihr was das heißt, ich bastel da zusammen mit einem Kollegen von der Arbeit
dran, das ist Max und Tim System Monitoring, aber wird wahrscheinlich keinem was sagen,
Agile as fuck, ja, für die Monitoring-Wand musste halt im Office sein, ja das ist kein
Problem, die sind im Office, bei uns ist, wir nennen es mal der Leitstand, das find
ich in Plumedia, das ist eine super Geschichte, der Leitstand ist bei uns 24-7 besetzt, sogar
in Corona-Zeiten vor Ort, Frühschicht, Tag, Tagsüberschicht, Nachtschicht, am Wochenende
sogar bis zu 12 Stunden am Stück, die gleichen Leute, die kriegen aber zum Glück ordentlich
Schichtzuschlag, sonst wird es glaub ich keiner freiwillig machen, und dementsprechend
kann man das dann auch ganz gut anpassen, man könnte zum Beispiel sagen, hey, wir machen
hier dann noch einen Button nebendran, dass man direkt dann beim verantwortlichen Ticket
erzeugen kann, was auch immer kann, das ist ja Custom, also das Ding erfüllt zwei Aspekte,
einmal ein Übungsprojekt für mich, dass ich ein bisschen mehr Frontendübung sammeln
kann, gerade im Zusammenhang ein bisschen mehr Svelte lernen, ein bisschen Crafql lernen,
ein bisschen Webdesign wieder ein bisschen lernen und auch was praktisches, wo dann im
Endeffekt einer was von hat, machen die noch First Level, ich weiß nicht wie genau die
Jobbeschreibung ist, aber die machen so ne Mischung, also es ist nicht reines First Level,
es ist nicht reines First Level so nach dem Motto, hoch, da ist was aufgeblinkt, ich schick
jetzt mal eine Message an XY und da geh ich wieder schlafen oder sowas in der Richtung
oder so, also früher wo ich beim Provider gearbeitet hab noch, da hatten wir ein richtig
echtes First Level, das waren bei uns drei Mädels und denen hat man gesagt, Sekunde,
muss ich mir aufschreiben sonst vergesse ich es nachher, so und denen hat man gesagt,
jegliche Mail die an, ich nenne es jetzt mal irgendwie support-provider.de geht, jegliche
Mail muss mit einem von verschiedenen Standardtexten beantwortet werden, so und die waren wirklich
First Level, die haben nichts gemacht außer diesen Vordruck zu verschicken bzw. wenn
irgendwie eine Meldung irgendwo aufgebloppt ist oder irgendwie einer was geschrieben hat,
das einfach weiter zu schieben, das war reiner First Level, die hatten keine Ahnung, die
wussten noch nicht mal was es geht, aber und man darf das nicht vergessen, First Level
muss auch seine Qualitäten haben, die waren alle sehr gut im Telefonieren, die hatten
alle sehr nette Stimmen, die konnten super mit Leuten reden, auch wenn die sich aufgeregt
haben, das ist ja was was ich überhaupt nicht kann, ich reg mich dann auch auf und kack
die Leute im Zweifel an, also dafür, die haben das echt gut gemacht, die hatten halt
von der Technik keine Ahnung, aber das war richtig echtes First Level und das hat teilweise
auch ganz lustige Blüten getragen, so dieses diese Mischung aus keine Ahnung und diese
ganz klare Vorgabe, jede Mail, die da ankommt, kriegt eine Standard Antwort oder kriegt
eine Antwort, jede Mail muss eine Antwort bekommen und ich war damals ausgeliehen, also
wie gesagt, als ich schon bei diesem Provider gearbeitet habe, ich war damals ausgeliehen
quasi an die Firma, wo ich jetzt auch arbeite in Frankfurt und da hat irgendeiner eine Mail
geschrieben an den Support vom Provider, aber hatte im CC irgendeinen aus dem Vorstand
mit drinne, so das heißt es kam beim Support beim First Level dort, kam eine Mail an, so
nach dem Motto, was weiß ich, System XY geht nicht mehr, aber im CC war irgendein Typ vom
Vorstand, so dann haben die da drauf geantwortet, natürlich Antworten an alle, haben da drauf
geantwortet, ja wir haben das Problem an den Techniker eskaliert und es wird mit Hochdruck
an der Lösung gearbeitet oder sowas in der Richtung, stand in der Mail drinne, so der
Vorstand-Typ war aber gerade nicht da und der Autoresponder hat geantwortet, da kam
dann von diesem Vorstand-Typ eine Autoresponder-Mail, bin zurzeit nicht im Büro und dann hat der
Support darauf, weil sie haben die ganz klare Anweisung gehabt, es muss auf jede E-Mail geantwortet
werden, haben die dann geschrieben, ich lasse den Namen jetzt weg, sehr geehrtes Vorstandsmitglied,
wir haben ihre Abwesenheit zur Kenntnis genommen, da hat er sich bestimmt gefreut, dass der
Provider Support die Abwesenheit zur Kenntnis genommen hat, also da sieht man manchmal
Tragen, so ultra-verbissenes Prozessgefolge bzw. verlangen, dass man das macht, sehr
merkwürdige Blüten und das, das war echt der Lacher, da waren wir uns heute noch drüber
lustig, wir haben ihre Abwesenheit zur Kenntnis genommen, so ok, wo sind wir jetzt stehengeblieben
Leute?
Ich bin schon eine Stunde online, noch keine Zeile hier irgendwie programmiert, also ich
habe es übrigens ein bisschen aufgeräumt im Vergleich zum letzten Mal, also ihr seht
vielleicht, das Backend sieht noch ungefähr genauso aus wie das letzte Mal, da hat sich
nicht so viel geändert, aber Frontend-technisch, ich habe das jetzt ein bisschen aufgesplittet,
wir haben jetzt eine Komponente für die Tabelle, wir haben eine Komponente für diese Sortier-Buttons
und wir haben eine Komponente für diesen Tabellen-Header, wo man nämlich die Sachen
hier sortieren kann, dann ist das alles ein bisschen ordentlicher und ihr seht auch, das
ist deutlich kürzer und übersichtlicher alles, so das ist alles, das ist quasi mehr oder
weniger der gesamte Quellcode, also es ist noch überschaubar, so und jetzt basteln wir
da heute einfach mal ein bisschen dran weiter, ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, wo wir anfangen,
wisst ihr was ich mir überlegt habe, da muss ich euch mal was fragen, was ihr davon haltet,
also zwei Sachen, die wir heute machen können, also erstens würde ich die Alerts noch ein
bisschen erweitern, dass man auch ein bisschen mehr Infos haben, die man anzeigen kann, zum
Beispiel eine ordentliche Summary, Description oder sowas oder ein Value, wo dann drin steht
keine Ahnung, Festplattenplatz unter 90% oder sowas, über 90%, das können wir noch ein
bisschen erweitern, aber wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin, guck mal, ich habe doch hier oben
so ein Filter eingebaut, also man kann quasi die Fehlermeldungen sortieren, also sprich
welches Environment ist das, ist das Entwicklung, ist das das produktive System oder ist das
das Testsystem, da kann man die danach sortieren, wie findet ihr das denn hier oben platziert,
ist das sinnig, weil, also für sich genommen geht das ja und sieht eigentlich auch ganz
okay aus, aber was mir eingefallen ist, was man eigentlich noch bräuchte ist, man müsste
noch Filtern können, nach oder bzw. raus Filtern können, Alerts, die man nicht sehen
will, also zum Beispiel ich möchte keine, also besser gesagt, ich möchte nur Warning
und Error und Critical haben, ich möchte keine Info Alerts haben, ja gut, wie ich das nenne
ist doch egal, Def, Non-Prot, Prot, das ist wurscht, das kann man im Endeffekt auch nennen,
wie man will, so und dann müsste ich hier unten drunter noch eine Leiste machen mit
Buttons für die, für die Störungsstufen, ach du meinst die Reihenfolge, die Reihenfolge
ist glaube ich automatisch zurzeit, muss ich mal gucken, ich glaube die Reihenfolge ist
automatisch alphabetisch sortiert, muss ich mal gucken, wo die, wo die, wo das gerade
herkommt, ich glaube das ist automatisch, Environments, ne wo hab ich das denn, Environments, Environments
from Stores, ok, ja, das, die Environments entstehen automatisch aus den Fehlermeldungen,
also der, der nimmt aus, der macht sich ne Liste mit allen Environments aus allen Fehlermeldungen
und so dass nur noch eins übrig bleibt, also da hab ich nicht so viel Einfluss drauf,
aber wahrscheinlich Hardcoden wir die später mal, weil es könnte ja sein, dass es gerade
keine Produktionsfehlermeldungen gibt, aber möchte vielleicht trotzdem noch live filtern,
du könntest auch links ein Filter-Icon machen, das ein kleines Kontextmenü öffnet mit Checkbox,
das finde ich ist ne sehr gute Idee, das finde ich ne super Idee, du meinst quasi sowas hier,
das, das, das, deswegen frag ich euch bei sowas, ja, weil ich müsste hier filtern nach quasi
ja, Environment, Umgebung und unten drunter müsste ich noch filtern nach Schweregrad und
dann hätte ich auch gerne noch ne Input-Box, wo ich zum Beispiel noch hier Volltext-Suche
machen kann oder sowas, das ist ne gute Idee, wir können zum Beispiel sagen hier Filter,
Filter, nehmen wir mal das Filter-Icon, gehen jetzt mal hier runter, so, machen wir mal
das Icon rein, sowas hier, guckt, dass wir jetzt da draufklicken und dann geht ein Kontextmenü,
was heißt Kontextmenü, dann geht so ein Overlay auf, wo dann die ganzen Sachen drin stehen,
mit Local Storage-Speicherung, sehr gute Idee, sehr gut, das machen wir auch noch, ja, schreibt
mir das mal auf, Local Storage, das finde ich ist ne gute Idee, so richtig feifetter
Chat wieder, way too smarter Chat heute, Local Storage-Speicherung, das ist auch ne gute Idee,
das sollten wir auch machen, dass sich das zumindest an Browser gebunden ist, so, dann
machen wir hier mal ein Icon hin zum Filtern und nehmen das mal raus, so, weil das brauchen
wir nicht mehr, gut, jetzt haben wir hier den Filter-Icon, machen wir mal ein Button draus,
dass man da auch draufklicken kann, Button, äh, warum kann ich den Button hier anklicken,
Debated, achso, wahrscheinlich weil das absolut ist, das müsste es eigentlich, boah, eeh,
jetzt kann ich das anklicken, ähm, Flex, Items, äh, äh, Between, pass mal auf, mal gucken,
ob ich Flexbox mittlerweile halbwegs gecheckt habe, hey, ich hab's verstanden, ist die
Dev Überschrift nicht redundant, äh, nee, warum, du musst doch wissen, auf welches
Grund Wireman sich die Tabelle bezieht, siehst du ja grad nicht mehr, achso, du meinst vorher,
ja, vorher hätte man sich sparen, das ist richtig, vorher hätte man sich das sparen
können, ja, das ist, das ist wohl wahr, so, und jetzt, und jetzt meint ihr, wir hatten
das geschrieben, ähm, wer auch immer das geschrieben hat, ähm, und jetzt meint ihr
hier so quasi so ein Pop-Up machen, wo wir dann Filter-Sachen, das ist für mich, das
ist eine gute Idee, das gefällt mir, das ist, das ist nice, das probieren wir mal, wie machen
wir denn jetzt hier am besten ein Pop-Up, also, erste mal, erste mal sagen wir, dass
der Button, Texts, Prey, äh, das ist ein bisschen dunkel, 400, sowas ist, und dann sagen wir
Hover, Text, Wide, so, was jetzt passiert ist, guck mal, jetzt sehe ich, dass ich da drauf
klicken kann, richtig POC, POC-Champ, so, und dann machen wir nochmal Margin, ein bisschen
Pop, sieh mir in der Mitte, ist so, sieht glaube ich besser aus, so ein Menü wird mobile
ziemlich gefriebelt, was wird man denn mobile-gescheit machen, was wird nur mobile-gescheit machen,
mal ganz nach vorne abgesehen, mobile interessiert mich wirklich nicht, mobile last Design-Philosophie,
ich sag mal so, funktioniert das, dass das schon, mach doch so ein Slide-Out, das neue,
dass eine neue Zeile kommt, ah, wir machen mal beides, Arrow, ja, wir machen mal beides,
ich check mal beides, wir machen mal wirklich, wir machen mal das Slide-Menü von am Anfang,
so guck mal, jetzt haben wir was, wo wir Sliden könnten, so, wir probieren mal beides aus,
wir haben ja Zeit, so, wir haben hier was zum, wir könnten sogar noch sagen Rounded, Circle,
BG, BG, Grey und dann irgendwas so mit Hintergrundfarbe oder so, ne, es ist nicht Circle, es ist Rounded
Full, oder, Order, oh, das sieht doch gar nicht so schlecht aus, na gut, für die Optik,
für die Optik sind wir jetzt nicht zuständig, wie könnten wir das Sliden lassen, davon
fragen, was das Ziel ist, ja klar, Radiant Tracer, Dankeschön für den Sub, das Ziel
ist ein, also ich hab ein Fake-Monitoring-Tool gebaut, was nix anderes macht, wie Fake-Monitoring-Meldungen
schicken und ich übe Svelte und Craft-QL und bisschen Frontend-Gedöns, weil mit CSS stehe
ich ja immer noch so ein bisschen auf Kriegsfuß, so und jetzt könnten wir sagen, es soll raus
Sliden, also jetzt mal irgendwie, Let Show Filter Menu oder so, machen wir mal True, dass
wir es standardmäßig einpletten können, so und bei einem Click, On-Click auf diesen
Button, soll das, ah Moment, ich guck gleich wieder rein, soll das sagen Filter Show Menu
Toggle, Toggle, so wenn ich jetzt alles richtig gemacht habe, dann sollte das, genau, umschalten
bei jedem Click, so und jetzt muss ich das irgendwie raus Sliden lassen, das heißt,
ich brauch hier unten drunter was zum Sliden, Class H12 oder so und da machen wir jetzt
ein Menü rein, da machen wir jetzt das da rein, zum Testen mal, wobei die Größe brauche
ich ja hier gar nicht anzugeben, das ist halt so groß, wie es groß ist, ja gut, das sieht
jetzt so gestaucht noch ziemlich kacke aus, aber das kann man ja noch alles anpassen,
keine Ahnung, H20, ja zum Testen ist das erstmal ok, da kann das ruhig kacke aussehen,
so Sliden, das heißt, oh Leute, ich hab die, wir machen jetzt Svelte Animation, so und
das hier rendern wir nur, If Show Filter Menü, ist das wie immer das Slash If, so, haha, wie
wäre es mit einem eigenen Block, ja das Dumme ist, eigentlich finde ich einen eigenen, also
finde ich den eigenen Block blöd, weil, wenn du das, dann hast du quasi immer was eingeblendet,
was irgendwie, keine Ahnung, dann ist quasi 30% vom vertikalen Monitor Space mit nicht
sinnvollen Informationen gefüllt, den Block kannst du toggle, na gut, das ist ja doch
ähnlich hier, oder, ja mal gucken, mal gucken, mal gucken was mir da einfällt schönes, so
also wir können das jetzt ein- und ausblenden, das sieht aber kacke aus, das ist die 3 als
Window Manager, korrekt, so und jetzt haben wir mal Svelte Transitions, mal gucken ob
ich das hinkriege, Import, Svelte Transitions, nein, erstmal richtig schreiben, Transition,
und jetzt wollen wir haben, ich glaube es gibt sogar Slide, slide, sehr gut, Arch by the
way, ja, jetzt wird es richtig advanced Leute, passt mal auf, so, mal gucken ob ich das jetzt
richtig verstanden habe, so Class Transition, nee das war Tailwind, Transition, Transition,
Slide, ich hoffe ich mach das richtig, Bam, Leute, huge, Slide Action, Gachi Bass, Hyper
Gachi, guck mal, es slidet, nice, ok das ist easy, ich mein, ehrlich gesagt, es sieht ziemlich
beschissen aus, mit dem rein und raus Sliding an der Stelle, das muss ich irgendwie anders
machen, aber von der Idee her finde ich es gar nicht mal so schlecht, Overlay, nee, weiß
nicht, ich bin irgendwie kein Fan von, ich mein, das müsste so ein Modal, Modal, wie
immer man das jetzt betont, Overlay sein, was du nicht wegklicken kannst, außer auf
ok zu drücken, nee, das finde ich nicht schön, zumal es ja auch live updaten soll, wenn du
den Filter was einträgst und dann musst du immer auf und zu machen und so, da kannst
du gar nicht richtig durchklicken, nee, das finde ich so eigentlich schon ganz gut, das
ist doch ein eigener Filter Block hier dazwischen, nur dass der ziemlich da oben dran hängt,
da müssen wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, dass der, der kriegt auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
Top, dass er Abstand hat, noch ein bisschen Abstand, so, ah das sieht doch schon besser
aus, ja ich mein, das ist ein ziemlich blödes Beispiel mit so einem einzelnen Ding, da müssen
wir jetzt noch eine Überschrift machen, was das eigentlich ist, also sprich, das hier
ist ja das Environment, nochmal H3, man könnte Dev, Live und Test standardmäßig anzeigen,
dann so einen Advanced Filter öffnen, das ist eine gute Idee, wisst ihr was wir machen,
wir zeigen das Filtern nach Alerts standardmäßig an und dann können wir Filtern danach, ja,
dann machen wir das mal, dann versuche ich jetzt mal den Filter zu machen nach Schwierigkeitsgrad,
dann kümmern wir uns um dieses Menü, kümmern wir uns gleich danach, ok, wie können wir
jetzt eine gescheite Anzeige machen mit den Schwierigkeitsgraden, weil ich habe das gestern
auf der Arbeit mal einem gezeigt, der sich diese Sachen angucken muss, der da im Leitstand
arbeitet und da meinte, es wäre gut, wenn man irgendwo sehen könnte, was die Farben
bedeuten, deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, wir könnten das so machen, mal gucken, ob das
gescheit aussieht, was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn wir, wie gesagt, ich weiß, dass es nicht
richtig angeordnet ist, wenn wir da sowas machen, also wir machen einen Diff und darin
machen wir jetzt so Tags, also dass man zum Beispiel sagt, hey, keine Ahnung, Glas, ich
mache irgendwie Breite, Breite 5 oder sowas und Ups, ja, Background machen wir dann die
gleiche Farbe wie den Hintergrund, also wie die Meldung, so und dann sagen wir rounded,
pull, da können wir so Tags machen, so und da schreiben wir jetzt rein, ja so oder Batches,
ja, wie auch immer man das nennt, da schreiben wir jetzt rein, das bedeutet Error, oh, ich
glaube, ich muss das hier weg machen, ihh, ah, es ist Flex, weird Flex Leute, weird Flex,
sowas in der Richtung, ich weiß, die Anordnung ist bescheuert und falsch, aber nur von der
Idee her, so, da können wir nämlich noch sagen, Texts, small, nee, ein bisschen zu small, so
und dann noch Padding 2, nee Padding 1, so wirklich hübsch ist das nett, Moment, äh,
warte mal, warum ist das jetzt nicht nebeneinander, warum ist das nicht nebeneinander, weil ich
noch sagen muss, Glas, Flex, weird Flex, so Abstände dazwischen 2, na das sieht doch
jetzt schon ein bisschen besser aus, ähm, da müssen wir Buttons draus machen, dass man
draufklicken kann, Komponenz, Batch, der Chat schickt mir irgendwelche Beispiele, zeig
mal her, ja die sind ganz hübsch, sowas, sowas in der Richtung will ich haben, wir
wollen normal rounded haben, nicht rounded voll, rounded, wobei, doch rounded voll haben,
ich mein ich hab schon schönere Batches gesehen ehrlich gesagt, das was ich da fabriziert
habe, was ist eigentlich mit der Graf, was, mit was, ach der Preischamp, der ist offline,
das war Pain in the Ass zu pflegen, weniger roundness, wir roundnessen weniger, ja, die
Tabelle blendet, ne, das muss so sein, du musst es, der Kontrast, der Kontrast ist ziemlich
gut hier würde ich sagen, und du musst es auch von weitem auf ner Wand erkennen können,
das ist Absicht, ich mein wir könnten, wir könnten mal gucken, ob man nicht die Farben
eine Stufe dunkler macht, aber dann ist der Kontrast nicht mehr so gut, oh Leute ich hab
die Idee, Pfeiffett-Time, Pfeiffett-Time, Sekunde, tailwind gradient, die machen jetzt
Farbverlauf, boah, meine Augen, hier, Massive, wir machen jetzt Farbverlauf, wir müssen so
ne richtige Farbe überlegen, warum geht das nicht, ich finde das würde auch reichen,
wenn du zum Beispiel am Anfang der Zeile eine 10 Pixel dicke Linie mit den Alertfarben
hast, das können wir ausprobieren, können wir testen, ähm, warum geht der Farbverlauf
jetzt nicht, ah From, From muss ich machen, oah, guck mal hier, Massive Farbverlauf, sowas,
ey From, ey das sieht gar nicht mal so mies aus, wisst ihr das, das sieht gar nicht mal
so schlecht aus, mal gucken, mal gucken wie das aussieht auf der kompletten Seite, ey
das sieht gar nicht mal mies aus, oder, das sieht eigentlich ganz gut aus, was meint ihr,
mit Farbverlauf oder durchgängig mit der Farbe, was ist besser, kann man diese Farben
nicht den Variabel packen, doch, doch, werde ich noch machen, allein schon, wenn du das
ganze Steam Bar machst, durchgängig, Farbverlauf, wir probieren mal was anderes aus, wir probieren
mal das aus, was Akira vorgeschlagen hat, und zwar, ne, äh, der Luni vorgeschlagen hat,
wir machen einfach das gleich, nur hier vorne eine Farbe hin, das können wir ja machen,
dazu machen wir nochmal den ganzen Krempel an Farbverläufen weg, und sagen jetzt, lasst
mal überlegen, wie könnten wir das machen, also wir machen nicht mal die komplette, wir
machen nicht mal die komplette Zeile mit dieser Farbe, sondern wir machen die erstmal alle
gleichfarbig, also nicht so, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht zu erkennen, Border 2,
rounded, warum ist das nicht rounded, ah, Moment, weil das von den Dingern innen kommt, kein
Border, kein Border, Border geht nicht, äh, BG Cray 700, sowas in der Richtung, und dann,
und dann meinst du, dass man einfach nur hier vorne quasi so ne Anzeige macht, was es denn
jetzt ist im Endeffekt, so, also sprich dort, wo jetzt steht, about 30 hours ago, machen
wir quasi nochmal was, und zwar, nee, has tooltip, mal kurz überlegen, wie man das,
wie wäre Status anzeigen von der Zeit, wie ein roter Kreis für neue Fehler, gelb orange
in der Warteplaufe, nee, nee, wir bauen hier kein Ticketsystem nach, ich mein man könnte
die Uhrzeit, man könnte die Uhrzeit mit ner Farbe anzeigen, aber das ist unterschiedlich
lang, das ist blöd, also wir werden wahrscheinlich sowas hier machen, muss ich mal ausprobieren,
Höhe, Full, Background zum testen, Red, ähm, keine Ahnung, 12, 12er Breite, ok ich muss
auch ne Höhe angeben, wie geht, hör mal auf, ähm, 8, so, und dann, ich will nur mal kurz
gucken, wie es aussehen würde prinzipiell, also du meinst quasi hier vorne sowas, ne,
ich mein jetzt ohne, du meinst natürlich nicht mit der, das nicht, dass die Schrift überschrieben
wird, aber von der Idee her, du meinst einfach nur vorne irgendwie so ne Anzeige, was es
ist, dass man da irgendwie nen Streifen hat oder sowas, welche Farbe es ist, also was
man hier quasi sagt, Alert, hä, warum importiert der Index, hä, das
hab ich aber nicht angegeben, hä, ähm, warum ist es jetzt Broken, das sollte eigentlich
schon unterschiedliche Farben haben, äh, ah, ok, das ist auch falsch, das ist auch
falsch geschrieben, oder, ja sowas in der Richtung, oder, bloß halt, dass wir jetzt
den Text noch ein bisschen weiter verschieben müssen, beziehungsweise wir könnten das
auch, sagen wir machen Left Null, wie Höhe 12 oder sowas, Top Null, relativ, ja im Prinzip
sowas in der Richtung, das, also wie gesagt ich weiß, dass das jetzt designtechnisch
an der Stelle nicht so gut ist, ähm, aber was haltet ihr sinnvoller, für sinnvoller,
die komplette, die komplette, das komplette Ding einzufärmen oder nur am Anfang so nen,
so nen, weil wie gesagt man muss das auch aus 2 Meter Entfernung auf ner Monitorwand
kennen, erkennen, wie sieht es aus, wenn nur die Zeit farbig hinterlegt wird, das sieht
kacke aus, weil, das kann ich jetzt schon sagen, dass es kacke aussieht, weil die Zeit unterschiedlich
lang ist, oder du meinst für den, ja mach Stripes, tu dir keinen Zwang an, mach ne Umfrage,
oder, wartet mal, machen das hier weg, ach die Umfrage ist schon an, stimmt, ja dann,
dann äh, zählt nur vorne 50% voll, ja 50% aber nicht ausprobiert, aber alle, alle sind
da mal, außer Luni, Luni meint, das ist nur vorne, das kann auch einfach ein Verlauf
von der Farbe in Grau als Witz, aber hier mega advanced CSS Shit, ähm, ich färb mal
nur die erste Zelle ein, schauen wir uns mal an, wie das aussieht, guck mal hier, so,
das sieht dann aber ziemlich abgehackt aus, oder, wenn nur die erste Zelle eingefärbt
ist, was ist rausgekommen, voll, okay, wie sieht das aus mit einer Linie oben drüber,
jetzt wirds aber, jetzt wirds langsam richtig hyper advanced, also anstatt so meinst du
im Prinzip, ähm, kann man sowas sagen wie voll geht das an der, lul, äh, Höhe eins,
sowas, im Prinzip meinst du sowas, oder, hm, dann weiß man nicht genau, welche das
ist, ich glaube wir bleiben bei komplett eingefärbt, Leute jetzt brauchen wir noch ne Umfrage,
eingefärbt, komplett eingefärbt, wo war man denn stehen geblieben, komplett eingefärbt
und dann mit Farbverlauf oder ohne, wie wäre es mit die erste Zeile verläuft von Alertfarbe
ins Grau, boah ne, das ist, das ist zu abgedrehtes CSS Zeug, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben
überhaupt, was ist denn hier jetzt, so jetzt, oder, jawoll, ne, aber Farben, ne aber, so
erkennst du es halt mit dem Weißgut, oder, ich mein, wie gesagt, man könnte, man könnte
ohne Probleme sagen, anstatt so, wohlgemerkt, es geht ja darum, man soll das ja sehen, also
es soll ja ins Auge springen, wenn da was ist, also quasi 900 oder wie, mal gucken ob
das besser ausschaut, ne, das sieht kacke aus, ein 600 würde ich mir noch gefallen
lassen, ich finde die Farbe eigentlich ganz passend, ich mein, du hast, du hast, warning
auf Orange, Info auf Blau, critical auf Purple und Rot auf Error, eigentlich passt das ja
so, zweiter Poll ist durch, durchgängig gleiche Farbe, ich zeige euch nochmal das mit dem
Farbverlauf, äh, wie war das, from, so, das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt mit, jetzt bräuchte
man ein Wim, das wird schneller gehen, so, das ist mit Farbverlauf, wobei wir es auch
umgedreht machen können, wir können auch sagen, das hier ist 800 und das da hinten
ist dann 600, wir halten uns an unsinnigen Sachen auf, das kann man immer noch ändern
später, oder vielleicht sogar nur 700, das ist ein ganz unauffälliger, also ich finde
gerade, deswegen ist es ja auch kein Rot, sondern es ist Fuchsia, ich finde da kann
man Orange und Rot in dem Fall ziemlich gut unterscheiden, naja, was heißt sehr weit,
die Leute haben irgendwie, keine Ahnung, einen 70 Zoll Monitor oder so, sitzen halt
ein bisschen weg, das passt schon, aber es soll halt ins Auge springen, das ist jetzt
halt ein sehr dezenter Farbverlauf, den erkennt man kaum, aber es ist ein Farbverlauf, das
muss man schon wirklich direkt miteinander vergleichen, dass man das, ich lasse es jetzt
erstmal so, so, jetzt kommen wir mal zurück zu meinen, zu meinen Badges, die ich da oben
gebastelt habe, der Arbeitskreisfarben, Farbenauswahl, ist es wirklich so, Designerstelle, ja ihr
wisst, wenn es um Designerzeug geht, da tue ich mir schwer mit, so, also wie können wir
das, lass mal kurz überlegen, wie können wir das hier oben denn mit den Tags schön
da machen, also wie gesagt, an die Stelle sollen die Tags nicht, also weder soll das
Ding hier dahin, noch soll das dahin, das ist jetzt nur, dass ich mir mal um die Optik
Gedanken machen kann, das mit dem Farbverlauf ist gar nicht mal so schlecht, dass es verläuft
von ein bisschen helleren zu ein bisschen dunkleren, das finde ich eigentlich ganz schick, so,
also, Error ist Ding, Critical ist Fuchsia, 600, so, und dann brauchen wir noch, was haben
wir hier?
Fond Medium, hat es das nicht gecheckt, warum hat es das nicht gecheckt, übergeordnet,
so, Fond Medium, dann ist das nämlich ein bisschen dicker alles, so, jetzt müssen wir
noch gucken, dass das, wenn ich mit der Maus drüber gehe, dass es einen Hover-Effekt gibt,
weil so sieht das ziemlich blöd aus, Leute, ich habe noch eine andere Idee, wir machen
das nach links und rechts noch ein bisschen breiter, wir sagen noch Padding nach links
und rechts, ja, so ist es besser, guck mal, da sticht das ein bisschen mehr raus, Padding
links und rechts machen wir noch, ja, so ist es schon viel, viel besser, ganz schick wäre,
Moment, was?
Ganz schick wäre das rote in ein Krauton und als Schrift ein Punkt in der Farbe und
danach, was, Moment, das, das mit, das habe ich nicht verstanden, ja, schön, dass du
hier bist, Chill Dude, wenn das Projekt auf Github schafft, weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt
auf Github hochzuladen, ich meine, das ist ein Übungsding gerade, Moin Fatals, 32 Monate,
wenn ihr wollt, ich kann es pushen, es ist reines Übungsding, als ob das hier zu Github
kommt, warum?
Die letzten Sachen habe ich auch zu Shithub gepusht, wo ich gesagt habe, ich push sie,
das ist ja nicht so, als mache ich gar nichts, was ich sage, manchmal mache ich was, die
To Do App ist doch auf Github, ja, genau, Kekwe ist das Service, ist auch auf Github,
und guck mal, jetzt haben wir Badges, was wir jetzt noch machen ist, ich habe eine Idee,
wir müssen, wir müssen ja dafür sorgen, dass es beim Hauvern, dass es beim Hauvern ein
bisschen ein Klick, Klick-Effekt, also ein Kann-ich-klicken-Effekt gibt, was ich glaube,
es ist gemeint, Hintergrund rot zu grau und dann einen Kreis mit rot vor dem Text.
Also du meinst, dass der Hintergrund faded von rot ins graue, ok, das habe ich verstanden,
und dann einen rot, einen Kreis mit rot vor dem Text, Alter, keine Ahnung, das sieht
aber glaube ich nicht gut aus, ein Aufzählungszeichen, du meinst, dass man hinschreibt, achso, du
meinst, man macht einen roten Punkt und dann schreibt man hin, gleich Error, ne, das kann
man nicht machen, weil es ist ja so gedacht, wenn du das anklickst, dann filterst du die
Sachen, also ich muss es jetzt so machen, dass du die anklicken und abklicken und wegklicken
kannst, genau, anklicken, wegklicken und dann filtert er für dich, so, aber ich finde,
das sieht jetzt erstmal ganz, ganz, ganz brauchbar, ja grauer Hintergrund, grauer Hintergrund
machen wir, wenn er weg, wenn er nicht aktiv ist, so, jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal probieren,
dass wenn man Hover macht, Hover, BG, Opacity, 90%, dass wir so ein bisschen, guck mal, dass
wir so einen kleinen Hover Effekt haben, das finde ich schon mal ganz nice, einen pockischen
Hover Effekt, so ok, jetzt was haben wir denn jetzt hier, wir haben einen Button mit Error,
wir brauchen noch einen Button mit Warning und wir brauchen noch einen Button mit Info,
der Button mit Info ist Indigo und das hier ist Orange, so, jetzt haben wir Badges am
Start und jetzt müssen wir da irgendeine Komponente draus bauen, scheiß drauf Komponenten
bauen, ich will jetzt eigentlich ausprobieren, wie es funktioniert, nicht Komponenten bauen,
also wir könnten da eine Komponente draus bauen, so und jetzt muss ich irgendwie dafür
sorgen, dass man die anklicken kann, beziehungsweise wieder abwählen kann, ok, also FyFatTime,
wir müssen jetzt quasi ein Array machen, wo immer drin steht, was man davon angeklägt
und wir machen ein Set, wir nehmen ein Set, weil in einem Set ist der Text einzigartig,
ok probieren wir das mal, let, wie nennen wir das Ding, Filter, Filter, New Set, so und
wenn man jetzt den Button anklickt, on, klick, dann sagen wir, ach ne ich muss Klammern drum
rum machen, wait, so dann sagen wir Filter n, add, Canon Critical oder so, so funktioniert
das jetzt, müssen wir mal checken, ob das funzt, Filter n, E-Object, Jason Stream, Leute
wie war das nochmal, ich habe es letztens gesehen, man konnte Debug davor schreiben
oder sowas, aber das funktioniert nicht Leute, warum geht das nicht, warum ist das broken,
auf, kann das sein, dass es nicht Stringified werden kann, to oder keys oder so, ne, kann
das sein, dass man nen Set nicht richtig anzeigen lassen kann, warum, warum ist, warum ist das
nicht Reactive, mache ich irgendwas falsch, Filter n, add, Critical, das müsste doch jetzt
eigentlich, was n an der Stelle, oder auch nicht, da bin ich jetzt ein wenig ratlos ehrlich
gesagt, warum das nicht funktioniert, gut, das kann ja auch, das kann ja auch so schon
mal gar nicht klappen, was ich hier gebaut habe, so, wir nennen das mal anders, ich lasse
das Set, wir nennen jetzt sowas wie Function, Filter, oh und dann F, du könntest Punkt
Längs machen, das gibt es bei einem Set glaube ich nicht, Chat ist still, hat keiner
eine Ahnung, ja, da wundert mich nicht, äh, die Elemente haben alle Attribute, die haben
Name, Source und Started Add und Severity intern, das kann man dann danach filtern,
aber ich muss mir jetzt ja erstmal merken, welche Knöpfe ich gedrückt habe, also, sagen
wir jetzt mal hier, if, wir nennen das auch Filter, buy, Filter, ist doch scheiß egal
wie das heißt, so, wenn das diesen Key hat, dann möchte ich diesen Key entfernen, weil
ich möchte es ja toggeln, also ich möchte ja mehrfach klicken können, so, klick aus,
klick an, klick aus, klick an, also es muss da immer hinzufügen, wenn es nicht drin ist
oder löschen, wenn es drin ist, so, if das ansonsten, Filter, Add, F und damit das Welt
glücklich ist, das nochmal zuweisen, dass es auf jeden Fall auch gesetzt wird, jetzt
habe ich, jetzt habe ich es gekillt, Filter Enf, na, es heißt ja auch nicht mal Filter
Enf, es heißt ja, es heißt ja jetzt auch Filter Severity, wie spricht man das überhaupt
richtig aus, so geht es jetzt, warum geht das nicht, was ist denn das hier, ich könnte
mir vorstellen, das funktioniert, das kann plötzlich Reactive angezeigt werden aus Gründen,
die ich nicht verstehe, wir tun einfach mal so, als würde es funktionieren, ok, so, wenn
ich das aktiviere, dann soll der Hintergrund die gleiche Farben haben, wie von dem Alert,
wenn ich es anklick, wenn ich es ausschalte, soll der Hintergrund grau sein, die Logik
musste mir nochmal erklären, naja, wenn ich hier drauf klicke das erste Mal, dann fügt
er das ein, wenn ich das nächste Mal drauf klicke, dann löscht das wieder, aber nur
wenn es schon drin ist, man kann das bestimmt mit und und oder oder oder sowas noch machen,
so, das heißt jetzt, probieren wir das an der Stelle mal aus, wir wollen haben nicht
dieses, also den BG, wollen wir haben, wenn, äh, warte mal, wenn, if, if der Filter has,
das kann man bestimmt schöner machen, ich kann aber schreiben, dann soll es 600 sein
und ansonsten soll es als Hintergrund BG grey 600 sein, das funzt, die Anzeige funzt einfach
nicht, guck mal, funktioniert, der Else Part, naja, wie gesagt, vielleicht kann man das
auch irgendwie schöner machen, wenn es, wenn es nicht drinne ist, dann edit er es, wenn
es drinne ist, dann löscht er es, einfach, dass ich den State habe für is critical jetzt
an oder ausgeschaltet, ja, weißt du, warum du das nicht lesen kannst, weil das die Pepega
Schreibweise von ifs ist, in Wirklichkeit müsste das if ja auch so da stehen, aber
dann ist der Chat wieder getriggert, weil er sagt, wer schreibt denn so seine ifs, würde
man nämlich das if so schreiben, dann hätte man das sofort erkannt, das ist auch eines
der Gründe, warum ich diese komische Dings da Schreibweise von ifs so nicht mag, so critical,
jetzt haben wir es ja eigentlich, jetzt haben wir es ja eigentlich, jetzt kann ich diesen
ganzen Shit hier mir schnappen, schnippschnapp, so, ohje, ich hab, ich hab irgendwas, ich hab
irgendwas zu, zu, ah, ich glaub, das hab ich nicht mit kopiert, so, so, Jose, ne, Ero,
was hab ich ver, was hab ich Pepega, was hab ich falsch gemacht, Leute, Ero, ach, ich
hab keinen on click, ja, ja, ok, Leute, das, da müssen wir glaube ich wirklich eine eigene
Komponente draus machen, weil das ist wirklich massiv eklig, was ich hier bastel gerade,
da ist vor uns, guck mal, kann man einen ausschalten, Pog, so, so, Info, Warning, zack, zack, zack,
Orange, Indigo, guck dir mal da, oh, MonkaS, aha, deswegen sollte man weniger copy pasten
und das als Komponente machen, so, nice, ja, das finde ich super, guck mal, das gefällt
mir, wir sollten das vielleicht noch, wisst ihr was, wir sollten das umdrehen, wir sollten
das umdrehen, das ist standardmäßig, dass es standardmäßig eingeschaltet ist, guck
mal, wir sollten das umdrehen, standardmäßig ist es eingeschaltet, ich kann es dann, und
ich kann es dann ausschalten, so, so, jetzt ist es standardmäßig ein und ich kann Sachen,
das ist nice, das finde ich richtig gut, das gefällt, ich meine, da oben ist es mega hässlich
und gehört nicht hin, aber von der Idee her finde ich das äußerst Pog, so, und jetzt
müssen wir den Filter machen, genau, ja, mache ich, mache ich, guck mal, man muss das zuweisen,
dass Welt in Change erkennt, dann funktioniert das, ich bin das, ja, ich bin das von YouTube,
tatsächlich, ich muss übrigens mal endlich wieder ein Video aufnehmen, wie gesagt, letzte
zwei Wochen, all die Chosen gings mir nicht so gut, aber jetzt, jetzt, jetzt habe ich
eigentlich keine Ausrede mehr, jetzt muss ich mal wieder ran, jetzt muss ich mal wieder
ein Vid machen, ist das aber nicht das gleiche, ob er, ob er das, ja, sobald du zu weißt,
ob er das, so, und jetzt können wir das filtern, guck mal, Filter, hier filter ich nach dem
Environment, also sprich, hier geht ja der Filter schon, aber wie gesagt, das da oben
kommt weg, das ist ja mega hässlicher Shit, so, jetzt heißt, ich kann jetzt noch einen
Filter machen, Filter, ähm, äh, Moment, Moment, wie mache ich denn das jetzt richtig?
Filter, äh, warte mal, wenn der nicht Filter, has, Liberty, oh, F, was ist jetzt, A ist
not defined, warum nicht, achso, weil ich es da vergessen habe, Leute, es funktioniert,
guck mal, nur Errors, Errors und Critical, Errors und Warning, ohne Info, easy, easy,
easy as fuck, easy, easy as fuck, und schon können wir filtern, oder nur Infos, oder
nur Warnings, Critical und Infos, das finde ich richtig gut, das gefällt mir, so, und
jetzt das ganze noch ins Dropdown, ne, ne, ne, was hatten wir gesagt, wir machen kein
Dropdown, wir machen das da, wir machen das daneben, dass man es dann ausfahren kann,
das testen wir jetzt mal, ob das, ob das tut, langsam wird die Komponente schon ein bisschen
zu lang, ich blicke nicht mal durch, wo ich, wo ich hin muss, wo, wo sich was versteckt,
hier, Button, yes, äh, MonkaS, warum ist das so fail,
Leute, es ist mir zu viel, ich blicke nicht mal durch, ok, das da, das da muss vor den
Button, das muss vor den Button, guck mal, so, und jetzt, Klaas, irgendwie haue ich mittlerweile
überall Flex drauf, weil es dann einfach funktioniert, Center, ne, das sieht nicht
schön aus, naja, fast, so, Gap, X, 2, 4, so, ich meine, das sieht beschissen aus, Leute,
das gefällt, das gefällt mir, guck mal, jetzt hast du jetzt zwar so ein Expand-Button, aber
das checkt doch keiner, oder, Leute, das, das, das, das, das versteht doch keiner,
der Text der Badges ist nicht vertikal zentriert, ohje, stimmt, du hast recht, ähm, wie macht
man das so, ne, Moment, hier ist ja der Button drin, Button, ähm, wie aligne ich denn den
Text im Button jetzt richtig, Text, Center, ist so, und jetzt, Align, wie, wie, wie aligne
ich den Text in der Mitte, auch mit Flex, noch mehr Flex, Flex in Weird-Flex, Alter,
Weird-Flex, Wart-Flex, Items, Center, Align, Middle, ne, Justify, Center, ne, da mag,
der lässt, der lässt sich nicht alignen, aber das stimmt, warum ist das nicht, warum
ist das nicht zentriert, warte mal, mal gucken, vielleicht ist optische Täuschung, ist das,
doch, das ist, Chat, das ist, hm, das ist zentriert, das sieht bloß nicht so aus,
ich glaube, das ist zentriert, schaut mal, das sieht nur bei 110 so ein bisschen broken
aus, bei 110 kommt da durcheinander, bei 100 siehts ok aus, bei 125 siehts ok aus, ob
das ist Monitoring-Skalierung, ups, was mach ich denn da, so, naja, also dieses, dieses
Slider-Menü, naja, da bin, da bin ich noch nicht so wirklich glücklich drüber, vielleicht
ist ein Pop-Up, irgendjemand hat am Anfang noch gesagt Pop-Up, oder, vielleicht ist ein
Pop-Up doch wirklich das beste, wir machen ein Pop-Up, das ist nur Überbleib, wir machen
einfach ein Pop, also hier ein Menü, was aufgeht, wo da eine Suchleiste drin ist, unten
drunter das Environment und unten drunter diese, diese Icons, ne, ne, ich mein kein
Pop-Up über die ganze Seite, einfach ein Menü, was aufgeht an der Stelle, also, im
Prinzip, ich muss mal was trinken kurz, im Prinzip meine ich das hier, da, wo wir jetzt,
wo wir jetzt Slide machen, also an der Stelle, das können wir schon mal komplett auskommentieren,
das brauchen wir nicht, Show-Filter-Menü können wir tatsächlich weiter verwenden, wobei
ne, passt doch, so alles gut hier, Show-Filter-Menü, so und wir machen das jetzt so, anstatt dass
hier irgendwas slidet, anstatt dass hier irgendwas slidet, wir machen einfach ein Absolute Positioning,
sagen ihm, keine Ahnung, ich stelle mir irgendwas ein, Weite 36, weißer Hintergrund, dass ich
sehe, wo es ist, ok, jetzt ist es irgendwo dahinter, oh, wir machen das Menü auf die
andere Seite, Bright Zero, oh, da sagt er doch schon mehr, wir machen einfach so ein
Menü, was hier aufgeht, hier geht ein Menü auf und da steht dann der ganze, ganze Schmodder
drin, das ist glaube ich deutlich, deutlich sinniger, ich mein, wir könnten das noch
ein bisschen schneller machen, das ist ganz schön langsam, Duration, ne, wie ging das
slide, Duration, 100 oder so, aber ist das auch responsive, naja, wenn ich die Höhe
und die Breite angebe, nicht, aber ich kann jetzt ja einfach sagen, ok, ähm, wartet
mal, Filter-Menü, das machen wir jetzt auf True, dass wir uns immer sehen, so, dass wir
das standardmäßig sehen, so, und da kopieren wir jetzt den ganzen Kram mal rein, also nehmen
wir das hier, Environment, wo ist das eigentlich hin, Environment sollte, ah, da steht Environment
drin, also Background-White ist schon mal blöd, Background-Grey 800 oder sowas, jawoll,
ähm, Border, kriegt einfach Grey 900, kriegt ein Rahmen, dann wird das rounded und es kriegt
ein Schatten, hat das jetzt ein Schatten, ich sehe da kein Schatten, ich vermute einfach
mal, das hat ein Schatten jetzt, alright, 4, so, gut, wunderbar, so, und jetzt machen
wir die Höhe und die Breite weg, und dafür kommt ein Item rein, so, ich meine, das sieht
noch beschissen aus, aber das können wir ordentlich stylen, noch ein Padding hin, ich glaube,
das ist der sinnvollere Ansatz, oder, ist vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt, wenn die Filteroption
immer sichtbar, da weiß man, dass die Filter angezeigt werden, falls von, ja, aber das Problem
dabei ist, du hast da schon nicht unrecht, das blöde ist, dass du halt ziemlich viel
Platz verschwendest auf deinem Monitor mit dauerhaft angezeigten Filteroptionen, weil
das reicht ja nicht, da muss noch eine Suchleiste hin, da muss das hier hin mit den Badges und
es muss an Environment Selection hin, und das verbraucht einfach zu viel Platz, dann
hast du ja ein Drittel vom Bildschirm quasi mit Adress, also mit Navigation Bar Überschrift
und Filterkram, deswegen war ja der ursprüngliche Gedanke, wir lassen das ein- und ausschleiten
hier unten drunter, da kann man das ein- und ausblenden, das ist eine Zeile, die dann belegt
es mit Filtern, ja, das ist dann aber ziemlich überladen, also ich würde es ehrlich gesagt
alles in so ein Menü reinpacken, so, wo haben wir hier die Badges, gucken wir mal, wie das
ausschaut, die Badges, oh ich habe irgendwas, was habe ich falsch kopiert, die Badges, Diff,
MKS, was ist dieses Diff hier, habe ich doch richtig kopiert, ach nee das da, das war gut,
so, deswegen macht man eigentlich auch Components, da plickt man besser durch, weil aktuell
ist das so viel Kram, da checkst du ja gar nichts mehr, guck mal, das ist doch keine
schlechte Idee, das ist doch wirklich keine schlechte Idee, dann sagen wir jetzt hier
On Medium, dann wird es ein bisschen dicker, dann sagen wir Margin Bottom 2, das ein bisschen
Platz dazwischen ist, dann ist das nicht Environment, dann nehmen wir das einfach Filter, komplett,
dann machen wir noch eine zweite Überschrift, die heißt dann Environment und dann machen
wir noch eine Überschrift, die heißt dann, ja so oder, das ist doch gar nicht mal so übel,
das kann man bestimmt noch schöner stylen, aber insgesamt ist so ein Popup doch angenehmer
als permanent oben was drin, vielleicht diese Wörter immer sichtbar und unwichtige Filter
an einem Untermenü, ja das hatten wir ja eben, das hatten wir ja eben, dass das hier permanent
angezeigt wird und die Filter hier drin sind, ja mal gucken, wie ich das mache, aber das
finde ich eigentlich relativ schick, so wie es ist, wir könnten übrigens die Margin
weg machen und mal gucken, mal gucken ob ich Flexbox irgendwie so langsam, aber sicher
halbwegs gecheckt habe, wir könnten sagen Flex Column, Flex Column, so und jetzt Gap
Y2, boah 5 hat Time Leute, Massive, was ist das eigentlich hauptsächlich zum üben,
da würdest du kleiner machen, ja hast du recht, äh nicht font, äh Texts, so ha, ja, nein
das sieht gar nicht scheiße, das sieht eigentlich ganz okay aus, muss ich sagen, das sieht eigentlich
wirklich ganz in Ordnung aus, wir sollen vielleicht noch das da auf die komplette Breite strecken
machen, oder, die, die Buttons, also wie machen wir das jetzt, Buttonbar, sorry, danke für
den Zap, bitte nichts, ja du hast recht, das ist bescheuert, dass es ein H3 überhaupt
ist, eigentlich können die einfach Diff nennen und sonst wie, aber du hast recht eigentlich
müsste es ein H4 sein, weil eigentlich überhaupt kein H, weil das ja keine Überschrift, ja,
das ist ja eh nur, äh, Tag, was es wirklich macht, das reinfordert vom CSS, so, wir gehen
mal in die, wir gehen mal in die Buttonbar rein und wir müssen jetzt gucken, dass das
volle Breite hat, geht das so, an der Stelle, no, no pass, ah, yes, exellent, severity musst
du immer sichtbar haben, ja, das ist schon richtig, hast du eigentlich recht, ja, wenn
ihr das schon sagen, wenn ihr das schon sagen, dann sollte man das vielleicht auch machen.
Hm, dann weiß ich aber nicht, wie ich es jetzt machen soll, mehr Padding, Bier, Zitronen,
zwei reicht doch, oder, ich glaube ja, dass man das gar nicht sichtbar braucht, sondern
man sich irgendwann merkt, wie die Farben sind für Arrows und sonst, wie man sie gibt,
vier verschiedene Farben, aber an sich ist das doch gar nicht mal so verkehrt, also mir
gefällt das ehrlich gesagt, so wie es ist, mir gefällt das, und jetzt, und jetzt bräuchte
man eigentlich noch, wobei die Überschrift, das ist ein bisschen klein hier, Text, nicht
Text SM, das gibt es sonst noch, Text, Base ist das normale, ne, ach komm, ich lasse es
jetzt erstmal so, wir bräuchten eigentlich noch eine Suchleiste, eigentlich bräuchte
man hier jetzt noch eine Suchleiste, nämlich eine Suchleiste für, wenn wir jetzt mal searchen,
wo man dann Volltextsuche machen kann, über die Felder, wenn wir search, input, oh, das
sieht kacke aus, ähm, warte mal, placeholder, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, das müssen wir jetzt
irgendwie ordentlich stylen, weil das sieht, das sieht mega beschissen aus so, man kann
ja in der Mitte von der Leiste eine horizontale Ampel machen, und das sind dann Kreise mit
aktivierten Farmen, du meinst keine Batches, sondern eine Ampel, das macht ja, ob das jetzt
eine Ampel ist oder Batches, das macht ja keinen Unterschied, das sah halt doof aus hier so
daneben, weiß nicht, übrigens, wo wir gerade dabei sind, da wo Def steht, das braucht
unbedingt noch eine Margin hier, weil sonst siehts kacke aus, wir stylen mal schnell den
Input, ich hasse zu Gmail, äh, ja, wie sieht es mit einem Time Range Filter aus, äh, ne,
ne, Time Select brauche ich eh für was anderes noch, aber das will ich mir jetzt erstmal
nicht geben, die Batches auslagern, ja, wohin denn, da oben, aber das sieht so deplatziert
aus, nach Name sortieren, das geht jetzt schon, nach Name sortieren funktioniert schon, kannst
nach Zeit sortieren, nach Name sortieren oder nach Quelle sortieren, das geht schon, sag
mal, ne, äh, roundet, äh, BG gray 700 oder 800, ah, Border, Indigo 600, das sieht tatsächlich
ganz brauchbar aus, oder, die Farben sollen so sein, die Farben sollen sein, dass man
die auch auf der Monitoring Wand aus 2 Meter, 3 Meter Entfernung sieht, und wenn du es nicht
lesen kannst, auf jeden Fall siehst, dass was aufgeploppt ist und was, das ist Absicht,
das soll Alarmemäßig aussehen, das sieht ok aus, das ist mir gefallen, so, ja, das
ist gut, achso, du hast recht, äh, Focus, ach, jetzt muss ich das Standard Ding wieder
überschreiben, äh, Focus, was war das, Null, ja, jetzt ist es weg, genau, dann mache ich
das, BG gray, oh, ne, das geht doch eigentlich, Placeholder haben wir ja schon, Punkt, Punkt,
Punkt, wie macht man eigentlich Placeholder Color, Placeholder, achso, ok, das habe ich
glaube nie gemacht, Placeholder Color, äh, Texts, red, ist es denn jetzt auch der Placeholder,
ey, nice, nice, nice, ich glaube gray 400 haben wir woanders auch für Texts, ja, das
sieht doch alles ganz ok aus, also ich könnte jetzt damit leben, ehrlich gesagt, so wie
es ist, die Batches sind nicht zentriert, ja, gut, ja, wie auch immer, ne, das finde
ich eigentlich ganz gut, so Leute, jetzt reicht es mir für heute mit CSS gebastelt, das ist
PaintsChamp, haben wir noch von gestern, wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit, haben wir
von gestern noch irgendwelche Sachen, die wir gucken können, Future Content, oh, Cut Content,
Data Mine, oh, ne, wir werden wieder Level Capture Baited, please, euch gelben mal kurz
auf Just Chatting, die Kategorie um, kein Stream, oh, speichern, die Stellangebote checken
wir jetzt nicht, auf Shitter pushen, ne, erst, also wenn überhaupt nur, wenn da irgendwas
Gescheites rauskommt, sollen wir, soll ich die Runde Battlefield Flame zur Abwechslung
mal wieder, können wir uns Tübaiten lassen, Future Content oder Cut Content, ne, ne, kein
Level Capture Bait, ne, wir machen keine Stellangebote in einer halben Stunde jetzt,
so everyone's been asked, oh, Leute, wir kriegen jetzt doch keine Videos, ich merke, dass ich
ein bisschen Kopfweh kriege, das sollte schnell wieder vorbeigehen, ich glaube, ich gehe
jetzt off, bad good time, zu viel CSS, ja, dann wird es einem auch schlecht und man kriegt
Kopfweh, alles in einem, schlechtes Kopfweh kriegt man dann, ich werd gucken, ich mach
morgen ein Video, und zwar, hab ich mir heute schon überlegt, ich hatte wieder jede Menge
sinnlosen Meetings die letzten Wochen über, ich muss einfach mal wieder ein Video machen,
wo ich mich über sinnlose Meetings auskotze, natürlich, wenn ich keine Namen erzähle und
ich werde es ein bisschen lustig machen mit ein paar Storys aus, ja, von unfähigen Leuten,
keine Ahnung, aber ich hab so viel unsinnige Meetings gehabt in letzter Zeit, das ist echt
der Wahnsinn, ich hab das Gefühl, ich werd nicht mehr bezahlt dafür, dass ich mich mit
Technik gut auskenne, sondern dass ich Excel, Confluence und Jira ordentlich befülle, das
ist wirklich witzlos teilweise, BWL Max, nee, so weit kommt es nicht, das hab ich hinter
mir, die BWL Geschichten, das Trello Board, hör mal bloß auf, damit fang ich das gar
nicht an, wir haben ein Kanban Board in Jira, niemand verwendet es, es ist einfach da und
sieht agil aus, und manchmal macht dann irgendjemand das Kanban Board Dashboard auf und zeigt
das und sagt, ah hier sieht man offen und geschlossen und danach wird es nie wieder
geöffnet.
Hast du Besprechung einfach abgesagt, ja hab ich auch schon gemacht, ich hab das ja mittlerweile
sogar schon so gemacht, dass man mich kaum noch einladen kann, also ich hab eh so viel
gemietet, dass es schwierig wird mit einladen, außerdem hab ich eingetragen, ab 15.15 hab
ich einen Feierabendtermin eingetragen, dass keiner auf die Idee kommt, irgendwelche Meetings
da einzuberufen, ich bin zwar 15.15 noch nicht weg, aber ich bin spätestens 16 Uhr
weg, 15.30 oder 16 Uhr, ich hab keinen Bock, dass irgendwer da noch ein Meeting um 15 Uhr
einstellt.
Wir haben einen Progas Channel im Discord, haben wir, haben wir, ich weiß nicht genau
wie der heißt, ich glaub Progas und Hilfe oder irgendwie sowas, aber haben wir.
Wie gehts dem Friseur, von dem hab ich jetzt schon eine Woche nichts mehr gehört, aber
das letzte Mal ging es ihm gut und er hatte kein Corona oder sonst was, er scheint das
alles bis jetzt ganz gut überstanden zu haben, hoffe ich hat sich nichts dran geändert.
Für dich ist 15 Uhr Primetime, für mich ist 15 Uhr Heimgehzeit, der Friseur da streamt
nicht so oft und wenn er streamt, streamt er in letzter Zeit so komische Weep Games irgendwie,
so Dinger da, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Mobile Weep Games, keine Ahnung was mit dem
abgehen, befrischst du auf, also aktuell stehe ich irgendwie so um 7 Uhr 15 bis 7 Uhr 30
auf und dann gehe ich rüber, setze mich an den Rechner und das erste was ich mache
ist, noch während der Rechner hochfährt, schreibe ich im Teams Chat Homeoffice Start,
weil das letztendlich auch die Zeiten für die Zeiterfassung bei uns sind und ich will
keine Sekunde verschenken, also während der Rechner startet, nehme ich das Handy extra
raus um zu schreiben Homeoffice Start, ich hab schon was zum Copy Paste, ich paste jeden
Tag den gleichen Startsatz rein, dass ich nicht immer neu tippen muss, Bot schreibt,
wir haben einen, wir haben einen, der hat das mit einem Bot, mit einem Teams Bot automatisiert,
das habe ich aber nur rausbekommen, weil im Teams hast du ja so Verläufe, also du hast
ja, wenn du eine Teams-Konversation aufmachst, also du kannst ja in so einem Teams Chat,
also da gibt es wieder keine Bilder von, also wenn es einen Channel gibt, aber Channel,
ich muss euch das zeigen, Teams Channel, Channels, und gibt es eigentlich nur so Dumme?
Ja, genau, also der Typ schreibt hier in diesem Channel was, so, und normalerweise machen wir
es so, der erste, der am Tag da ist, der schreibt halt in diesem, wir haben so einen Homeoffice
Status Channel, so der erste, der da ist, schreibt halt in diesem Homeoffice Status Channel,
ja ich fange jetzt an, und alle anderen antworten ihm dann da drauf am gleichen Tag, dass es
nicht so Gespamme gibt, so und wir hatten einen Kollege, der hat immer eine neue Konversation
in diesem Channel aufgemacht, und irgendwann bin ich dahinter gekommen, warum das ist,
weil sein Bot kann natürlich keine Replies, aber sein Bot kann ja eine neue Konversation
erstellen, und der Grund warum der nie Replied hat ist, weil der morgens irgendeinen Bot
hatte, der geschrieben hat Homeoffice Start, das hat er auch zugegeben dann, ist ja auch
nichts Schlimmes dabei, wenn die Zeiten stimmen, das fand ich nur insofern witzig, dass ich
dachte, das muss doch was dahinter stecken, bin ich dann drauf gekommen, das ist der Bot,
geht bei euch eigentlich 100% Homeoffice aktuell schon, aber nachdem wir ein Business Banken
Enterprise Boomer Stonks Unternehmen sind, sind die in der Führungsetage noch nicht
so weit 100% Homeoffice generell anzubieten, und ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt
am 20. wenn die Homeoffice Pflicht ausläuft, also ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, ich
werde definitiv nie wieder die ganze Woche nach Frankfurt fahren, und auch nicht die
halbe Woche oder so, das mach ich nicht mehr, das liegt einfach an ganz vielen Gründen,
ich krieg mehr geschafft, ich bin viel entspannter, es geht mir gesundheitlich besser, ich spare
massig Zeit und ich muss mich nicht über die Bahn rum ärgern und noch viele mehr Punkte,
warum es eine dumme Idee ist nach Frankfurt zu fahren, vor allem alles was ich mache ist
vom Rechner sitzen und mich um irgendwelche Sachen kümmern, so ob ich jetzt vom Rechner
daheim sitze oder vom Rechner auf der Arbeit sitze, ist egal, es macht keinen Unterschied,
ich mach sogar die gleichen Sachen, ich krieg sogar es von mir von daheim besser hin, weil
ich hier mein Setup hab, ich hab meine Tastatur, meine Maus, mein Mausbett, mein Stuhl, alles
sowieso, also ich kann sogar noch besser das ganze machen, ne, besserer Stuhl nicht, das
ist der gleiche Stuhl wie auf der Arbeit, in meinem Fall, wie gesagt ich sag ja nicht,
dass es bei jedem der Fall ist, ich kann mir das durchaus vorstellen, wie man das ja teilweise
in manchen YouTube Videos sieht, wo ich mich ja schon ein paar mal drüber lustig gemacht
hab, so Mutter sitzt in der Küche, macht Homeoffice, Kinder rennen rum, ein Stuhl ohne Arm lehnen
und sowas, ja kein Wunder, dass du da kein ordentliches Homeoffice machen kannst und Rückenprobleme
hast und dass nix klappt und nix auf die Reihe kriegst, du brauchst schon ein gescheites
Büro mit nem gescheiten Arbeitsplatz, aber wenn man das hat und wenn man so ein antisozialer
Mensch ist wie ich, der eigentlich am liebsten nichts mit anderen Menschen zu tun hat, noch
weniger in RL, dann ist Homeoffice das Beste was es gibt, was ich witzig fand bei uns auf
der Arbeit, wollten sie uns das ja so verkaufen, mal kurz was trinken, wollten sie uns das
ja so verkaufen, ja die Firma achtet auf ihre Mitarbeiter und achtet auch darauf, dass man
nicht vereinsamt, das war eine Umschreibung von es gibt kein Dauer Homeoffice, nicht zu
sagen wir erlauben euch kein Dauer Homeoffice, nein nein wir machen das nur zu eurem besten,
selbstverständlich, na klar, jebaited, jebaited, ja ich hab ja auch einen höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch, ja hab ich, hab ich, also nen Stuhl hab ich, also ich hab nen höhenverstellbaren
Stuhl mit verstellbarer Lehne, mit 3D verstellbaren Ablehnen, links, rechts, oben, unten, vorne,
hinten, du kannst die Sitzplatte oder wie man das nennt verstellen, nach vorn nach hinten,
die Empfindlichkeit der Rückenlehne oder ganz fest machen, aber meinen Stuhl empfehle
ich dir nicht, weil mein Stuhl ist wenn du den nicht im Angebot bekommst unsinnig teuer,
ich hab einen als Stuhl, so das ist der beste Stuhl den ich kenne, ohne Scheiß den hab
ich mir absichtlich gekauft, aber so die normalen Preise von diesem Stuhl sind halt nicht feierlich,
auf der anderen Seite muss ich mal überlegen, wenn man jeden Tag wie ich 10 plus Stunden
da vorsitzt und damit auch irgendwo sein Geld verdient, dann kommen einem 1500 Euro
für nen Stuhl zwar sau viel vor und wie ist es jetzt auch nicht, also nicht dass ich gesagt
hab, jawoll ich darf 1500 Euro ausgeben, dann ist es gar nicht so schlecht, du hast den
Senus Mr.
Charm, ok, sind bestimmt genauso teuer, nee, kostet, ist der 102, ohne Scheiß ist der beste
Stuhl den ich je hatte, ich würd mir auch nie einen anderen Stuhl mehr kaufen, ja es
ist ähnlich wie mit nem guten Klo, natürlich kann man nen 100 Euro Billig Klo nehmen oder
man kann sich nen gutes Klo kaufen, so und für die, keine Ahnung, 20 Jahre wo man so
nen Klo hat und wie oft man da am Tag drauf geht, ist ein bisschen bessere Investition,
ein bisschen höhere Investition gar nicht so verkehrt und so ist es mit nem Stuhl auch,
wenn man das oft benutzt und vielleicht auch mit normalen Sachen nicht so ganz zufrieden
ist sollte man es machen und gerade wenn man jemand wie ich ist, der so viel vorm Rechner
sitzt, das wichtigste ist aber und ich kann das nicht oft genug betonen, das wichtigste
ist aber tatsächlich, dass man sich am Tag mal so eineinhalb Stunden ein bisschen bewegt,
das muss nicht der krasse Fitnessstudio Krime sein oder auch nicht irgendwie hier super
schweißtreibend oder so, aber man muss sich am Tag mal so 1-2 Stunden bewegen, man kann
den Boomer Spaziergang machen, ja man kann, was weiß ich noch nen Hund hat, Gassi gehen,
man kann ins Fitnessstudio gehen, man kann draußen sich sportlich bewegen, wie auch
immer, jeder was er mag, aber 1-2 Stunden am Tag bewegen, am besten noch an frischer
Luft, das hilft unglaublich viel, ich hab kaum noch Kopfweh, ich hab kaum noch irgendwie
so Kreislauf-Geschicht-Probleme sonst was, mir tut der Rücken nicht mehr weh, mir tut
nix mehr weh, ich bin komplett fit eigentlich und einfach nur durch ein bisschen Bewegung,
die Chance hält, genau, ja die Sedos Stühle sind auch wirklich gut, ich weiß, dass die
ganzen Leute im Internet Werbung machen sagen, Hermann Miller ist bester Stuhl, aber ganz
ehrlich, ich hab den Vergleich nicht, aber es gibt nichts, wirklich gar nichts, was mich
an diesem Stuhl stört, ich würde mir diesen Stuhl jederzeit wieder kaufen, ich wüsste
gar nicht, warum ich einen anderen Hersteller kaufen sollte und ich bezweifle, dass ein
anderer Stuhl mich so zufriedenstellen würde, wie den ich hier habe, ich mein, man muss
sich mal überlegen, ich kannte den Stuhl ja von der Arbeit schon und ich hab allen Ernstes
gesagt, ich kauf mir privat einen 1500 Euro Stuhl, also allein schon, dass ich das gemacht
habe, sagt ja, dass ich da überzeugt gewesen sein muss von, nein, ich hab keinen Hermann
Miller, aber ich weiß, dass da viele drauf schwören, höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch
ist auch nice, die Sache ist bloß die, ich bin zu faul, den zu verwenden, was weiß ich,
wenn ich den einmal in der Woche hoch und runter fahre, ist das schon viel, aber wie
gesagt, ordentliches Equipment ist wichtig, sei es Monitore, sei es Tastatur, sei es Rechner,
gerade wenn man viel im Homeoffice ist oder gerade wenn man viel am Rechner macht, das
muss gute Hardware sein und gutes ergonomisches Equipment, da gibt es keine allgemeingültiges
für alle, es hat jeder seine Vorlieben, es gibt ja sogar Leute, die wollen Stühle explizit
ohne Arm lehnen, weil sie ihre Ärmel auf den Tisch legen, die sitzen dann so CSGO competitive
Turnierstyle vorm Rechner, am besten auch mit angewinkelter Tastatur und sowas, mag es geben,
aber mein Fall ist es nicht, ihr habt richtige Ranzstühle, klappen random nach hinten, das
könnte aber mal ins Auge gehen, vielleicht nicht, das ist die falsche Seite, so mal in
Kopf gehen von hinten, wenn das so random nach hinten umklappt, dann fällt man ja runter,
im Zweifel zerrt man sich noch irgendwas oder noch schlimmer, man haut mit dem Kopf irgendwo
dagegen, ich bin mal in der Schule richtig auf die Fresse geflogen, kennt ihr das, so
Leute, die den ganzen Tag kippeln mit dem Stuhl in der Schule, die nie gerade sitzen
in der Schule, sondern immer so 45 Grad mit dem Stuhl nach hinten und dann am besten
an die Wand gelehnt mit dem Stuhl, das habe ich auch gemacht, immer, ich habe nie normal
da gesessen mit dem Stuhl in der Schule und ich bin einmal richtig aufs Maul gefallen,
aber es hat sich nichts geändert, also ich habe immer noch so da gesessen, irgendwann
war ich halt mal wirklich gefühlt, keine Ahnung, 80 Grad Winkel oder so, ich habe fast schon
gelegen mit dem Stuhl und dann ist er halt nach vorne weggerutscht, ich bin aufs Maul
gefallen, ist aber nichts passiert, hat mich nur erschreckt, aber ich habe danach genauso
weiter gemacht. Umso größer der Winkel der Tastatur, desto
besser der Spieler, manche CSGO Pros haben ja ihre Tastatur wirklich 90 Grad vor sich
stehen und greifen dann so rum, das brauchen die aber glaube ich, weil die sonst ihr 2
Meter Mousepad nicht auf den Tisch kriegen. Ne, das mag ich nicht, das mag ich nicht,
das hatte ich früher, ich hatte früher so einen Computertisch, wisst ihr so die klassischen
Computertische, die man sich früher so gekauft hat mit ausziehbarer Tastatur, wo du so ein
Brett unten hattest und eine Tastatur, die du rausziehen kannst und das hat mir nicht
gefallen, das hatte ich jahrelang, aber jetzt, ich habe jetzt einfach eine stinknormale Tischplatte
mit einem Höhenverstellbaren Gestell unten drunter, fertig. Viel besser, braucht man alles
nicht. Ich hatte dann auch so einen Gestell oben drauf, wo man den Monitor so ein bisschen
erhöht hinstellen kann, dabei will man gar nicht nach oben gucken für den Monitor, man
möchte möglichst gerade vielleicht ein bisschen nach oben oder ein bisschen nach unten vorlieben,
aber man möchte nicht den Kinoblick so erste Reihe nach oben haben für den Monitor, man
will eigentlich gerade auf den Monitor gucken. Was ich aber auch gar nicht verstehe sind
Leute, die irgendwie auf ihrem kleinen Schreibtisch, mein Schreibtisch ist relativ lang, der ist
keine Ahnung, 2 Meter lang oder so, das ist ein ziemlich großes Teil, aber der ist halt
nicht so tief. Ich sehe Leute, die haben nicht so einen tiefen Schreibtisch und teilweise
dann da irgendwie ein 34 Zoll Monitor oder so was drauf stehen, wo ich mir dann immer
denke alter, wenn du vor dem Monitor sitzt und unten links hinguckst, siehst du oben
rechts schon gar nicht mehr so groß ist das Ding. Ich habe auch zwei Monitore, aber nicht
am Arm, stehen einfach auf dem Schreibtisch. Zwei Monitore ist glaube ich eines der besten
Produktivitätsbooster, die es gibt. Zwei Monitore ist das beste. Es muss ja noch nicht
mal so sein, dass du permanent zwei Monitore verwendest in deinem Workflow, aber es ist
einfach praktisch einen zweiten Monitor zu haben, sei es für einen Stream-Namen beilaufen
lassen, E-Mail-Programm-Namen beilaufen lassen, zwei weitere Browser-Splits offen zu haben
mit irgendwas zum drauf gucken. Drei Monitore habe ich auch mal probiert, das war mir persönlich
zu viel. Da war ich zu umringt von Monitoren. Also ich habe zwei, aber auch keine sonderlich
großen. Das sind, glaube ich, beides 24 Zoll-Monitore. Das könnte man machen, aber dann,
ich will immer noch drüber gucken können auf die Wand. Hast du da Linux-Only oder auch
Windows? Das hier ist Windows, das hier ist Linux. Linux, Windows. Windows, Linux. Windows,
Windows, Linux. Ja, das können wir jetzt beliebig oft machen. Ach, auf der Arbeit. Auf der Arbeit
habe ich, ja, da hast du jetzt einen wunden Punkt angesprochen. Das habe ich euch auch
schon ein paar Mal erzählt. Die sind ja bei uns auf der Arbeit gerade so ein bisschen
am alles so secure machen, dass du eigentlich gar nicht mehr richtig arbeiten kannst. Ich
habe aktuell ein Windows-Notebook und ein Linux-Notebook und eine Windows-VM. Aber das
Windows-Notebook verwende ich nicht, weil das Windows-Notebook hat keine Firewall-Freistelle
und kommt nirgends wohin, kann ich nicht gebrauchen. Wie switchst du so easy zu Linux? Das ist
eine VM. Hier, VM war Workstation im Fullscreen, allerdings so eingestellt. Und du kannst mit
Ctrl-Windows-Taste, kannst du desktops durchswitchen in Windows 10. Hier unten kannst du mit diesem
Ding kannst du dir zusätzliche Desktops anlegen. Und ich gehe einfach auf den zweiten Desktop,
bin drin, gehe hier wieder raus, gehe auf den ersten Desktop. Das einzige, was du machen
musst, ist, dass das geht. Also wenn ich jetzt hier Ctrl-Windows-Links-Rechts drücke, dann
geht das nicht. Du musst erstmal Ctrl-Alt drücken, dass du aus der VM rauskommst. Ctrl-Alt
und dann Ctrl-Windows-Links, Ctrl-Windows-Rechts und wieder reinklicken. Easy. Da gewöhnt
man sich dran, geht mittlerweile schon in einem Guss. Ja gut, mit WSL brauchst du es
ja gar nicht mehr. Da hast du kein Fokus mehr, Problem wie bei VM mehr. Das blöde
an WSL ist, dass, also gerade an WSL 1, dass du halt keine gescheiten GUI-Anwendungen verwenden
kannst zu der Linux. Das ist ja mit WSL 2 angeblich jetzt deutlich besser. Konnte ich
noch nicht ausprobieren, weil es in der VM nicht funktioniert. Weil es halt WSL 2 nested
Virtualisierung wäre. Ja, bei mir ist es auch so. Also ich mach halt die Standardsachen
von Videogramm, Fotogramm, also Thumbnails für YouTube, Videogramm für YouTube und
Spielen und halt Sachen, die nur unter Windows gehen, mach ich halt unter Windows. Aber ansonsten,
ich bin eigentlich, ja, würde schon sagen, sogar eher 60-70% des Tages in der Linux
VM. Also wenn ich den Arbeitstag mitrechne. Also nur wenn ich den Arbeitstag mitrechne,
ansonsten nicht privat kommt es an, was ich mache. Bestimmt 60-70% in der Linux VM.
Ist vor allem der Workstation Pro es wert? Ja, finde schon. Und ich würde mir keine irgendwelchen
gerippten Keys oder sowas hier holen, was der Chat da wieder für komische Dinge ausschreibt.
Ich würde mir das kaufen bei irgendeinem Keyshop, weil es gibt bei Keyshops für teilweise
10-15 Euro die Keys, 20 Euro die Keys. Dafür lohnt es sich. Ich suche im Moment nach einem
Ausbildungsplatz. Kannst du ein bisschen Ratschläge geben? Ja, was willst du denn wissen? So random
Ratschläge, du kannst auf YouTube gucken. Ich habe jede Menge Videos gemacht, was Ausbildung
angeht. Komm, mit dem Noel habe ich sogar ein Video, da fällt mir kein. Stimmt, tatsächlich.
Hey Leute und herzlich willkommen. Mit dem habe ich sogar ein Video gemacht dazu. Also ich habe
jede Menge Videos gemacht. Das musst du für deine Fachinformatiker-Ausbildung wissen, der
erste Arbeitstag und alles Mögliche. Also wenn du was wissen willst, musst du jetzt hier auf
Twitch schon konkret fragen, weil ich kann das ja nicht alles jetzt nochmal wiederholen.
Aber das weiß ich gar nicht alles, was ich in den letzten 12 Jahren an Sachen schon gesagt habe.
Übrigens habt ihr gesehen auf Twitter. Twitter EA Sports. EA Sports. Ja, die russischen Teams
wurden jetzt aus EA Spielen entfernt. Und da dachte ich mir so, ja gut, jetzt ist die Welt
natürlich in Ordnung. Jetzt ist Krieg vorbei. Jetzt ist allen geholfen, weil die nicht mehr in
EA Spielen drin sind. Das ist halt einfach so eine Predicted Marketing Aktion. Die Marketing
Abteilung hat gesagt, wir müssen jetzt irgendwas machen, was uns gut dastehen lässt. Ja, lass mal
die russische Mannschaft aus FIFA entfernen. Ja, super geiler Marketing Move. Und vor allem
ultra-low Effort, kostet kein Geld, ist einfach nur irgendwie in irgendeiner Datenbank irgendein
Häkchen setzen und helfen tut es im Endeffekt keinem. Man könnte, wenn man böse wäre, wenn
man böse wäre, könnte man sogar sagen, nachdem es ja ein reiner Marketing und Image Move ist,
wenn man böse wäre, könnte man sagen, die verdienen am Krieg sogar noch Geld. Deswegen
die sollen einfach die Klappe halten und dann Spielefirma, Spielefirma sein. Oder halt alternativ,
wenn sie wirklich was machen wollen. Es ist ja nicht so, als hätte EA kein Geld. Aber dieser
Move ist einfach rein kalkuliert Marketing, Image, Post, sonst nichts. Okay, etwas konkreter. Bei mir
in der Umgebung gibt es fast nur Anwendungsentwicklung. Ist das mit Systemintegration zu vergleichen,
beziehungsweise wie stehen die Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten? Also die Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten
sind immer ganz entscheidend davon abhängig, was du kannst. Das macht erst einmal keinen Unterschied,
ob du Anwendungsentwicklung oder Systemintegration gelernt hast oder aber ob du einen von den neuen
Fachrichtungen gelernt hast. Es gibt ja jetzt auch noch Daten und Prozessanalyse und digitale
Vernetzung. Gibt es ja jetzt auch noch. So, das ist erstmal ziemlich egal, was du da in der
Ausbildung, welche Ausbildung du dir aussuchst. Das macht jetzt keinen großen Unterschied. Vielleicht
je nach Schwerpunkt, also wenn du lieber programmierst, ist das natürlich sinnvoller. Wenn du keine Ahnung
Netzwerksachen bastelst oder Linux Sachen machst, ist eher das. Aber ganz ehrlich, die beiden
Ausbildungen haben, gerade auch wenn man sich mal im Hinblick auf Berufsschulen und sowas guckt,
da ist kein großer Unterschied dazwischen. Der größte Unterschied ist natürlich dann im Betrieb,
was du machst, beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich, wo der Schwerpunkt liegt. Aber es ist nicht so,
dass wenn du Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt hast und dich in einem Bereich gut auskennst,
die Leute dann sagen, ach nee, hättest du mal Systemintegration gelernt, dann würden wir dich
nehmen. Als Anwendungsentwickler nehmen wir dich nicht. Das ist Schwachsinn. Es kommt am Endeffekt
drauf an, was du kannst. Natürlich muss man sich auch ordentlich irgendwie verkaufen können,
aber du musst halt Ahnung haben von dem, was du machst, beziehungsweise von deinem Gebiet. Am
besten ist natürlich, du hast Ahnung in einem Gebiet, was du gerne machst. Das hat nämlich
zwei Vorteile. Dadurch, dass du das gerne machst, wirst du wahrscheinlich relativ schnell ganz gut
drinne, weil es dir Spaß macht beim Lernen. Und umso besser du da drin wirst, umso höher sind die
Chancen, dass du auch in diesem Gebiet arbeiten kannst. Also, das ist eigentlich, wie sagt man so,
Win-Win. Natürlich kann man sich nicht immer aussuchen. Ich muss auch genug Dinge machen,
wo ich keinen Bock drauf hab. Zum Beispiel irgendwelche Excel-Tabellen mit Service-Level
oder irgendeinen Stuss ausfüllen. Da kommst du nicht immer dran vorbei, auch mal Kacke zu machen,
die du nicht machen willst. Oder irgendwelche fünf sinnlosen Meetings am Tag. Da kommst du
nicht drum herum. Aber die Unternehmen stellen dich ja ein, weil du was kannst, weil du einen
Mehrwert irgendwie für sie hast. Und denen ist vollkommen egal, ob du Anwendungsentwicklung
oder Systemintegration gelernt hast. Danach sucht ja noch nicht mal jemand danach. Du wirst kaum
jemand finden, der nach einem Fachinformatiker Systemintegration sucht. Die suchen dann,
keine Ahnung, nach einem DevOps-Engine, nach einem Full-Stack-Entwickler, nach einem Frontend-Entwickler,
nach einem Java-Entwickler, was auch immer. Und niemand sucht nach einem Systemintegrator oder
sowas. Die haben ganz spezielle Vorstellungen, was du haben willst. Dann steht dann manchmal
drinnen mit Studium, vergleichbare Ausbildung, was auch immer. Dementsprechend ist vollkommen
egal, was du gelernt hast. Du musst was können. Das ist der eigentliche Punkt. Du musst irgendeinen
Mehrwert bieten. Wenn du der 150. Windows-Klicker bist, der außerdem AD, Start-Assistent durchklicken
nichts kann und Drucker einrichten. Ja, so Leute braucht man auch. Aber so Leute braucht man nicht
so viel, wie es davon gibt. Und von den Qualifikationen her wirst du davon auch nicht reich. Du musst
halt schon was können. Und du musst halt auch am besten was können, was nicht irgendwie 500 andere
Leute Schlange stehen. Wie war das? Bedge? Ja, Bedge ist demnächst. Zehn Jahre Berufserfahrung
aus der Ausbildung. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm. Natürlich schwebt das manchen vor. Das ist aber
glaube ich eher bei den Amis so. Schwebt das manchen vor, so nach dem Motto 20 Jahre Kupanitas
Erfahrung. Wo ich mir dann auch denke, oder was hatte ich letztens? Was war das denn? Auch
irgendwas, was es noch gar keine zehn Jahre gibt. Ich glaube, das haben wir uns sogar im Stream
angeguckt. War Ansible Erfahrung oder irgendwie sowas? Swift Erfahrung? Ich weiß nicht. Auch
irgendwie zehn Jahre Erfahrung, wo wir dann geguckt haben, ja da kam die Beta raus. Also
du musst quasi, entweder warst du Beta Tester damals oder bist Core Entwickler gewesen. Das
ist natürlich Schwachsinn, da hat die Personalabteilung irgendwie Blödsinn reingeschrieben. Was ist
deine Meinung zu Teamleiter während der Ausbildung? Du kannst als Azubi doch keinen Teamleiter
machen. Als Teamleiter hast du in einer wie gearteten Variante immer Verantwortung für
das Personal dort und das kannst du nicht als Azubi machen. Du bist ja als Azubi noch
nicht mal verantwortlich für dich selber so richtig. Wie kannst du dann verantwortlich
sein für irgendwelche anderen Mitarbeiter? Das würde mich doch sehr wundern. Teamleiter
ist keine Ausbildung. Das ist irgendeine Stelle, die irgendeine Firma, irgendein Unternehmen
besetzt haben will. Das ist aber keine Ausbildung. Es gibt keine Teamleiter-Ausbildung. Also es
gibt, wenn man denn Teamleiter ist, irgendwelche komischen Rhetorikkurse und sonst was, was
man machen kann, aber keine IHK-Ausbildung zum IT-Teamleiter oder sowas. Das gibt's
nicht. Dr. Pro, also Dr. Pro, ich hab's falsch gelesen. Dr. Pro Noob X. Danke schön für
den Sub. So, wenn ich die Ausbildung zum Anwendungsentwickler gemacht habe, ist es auch möglich beispielsweise
Frontend, Backend, Def-Zoo. Natürlich, warum nicht? Muss ich dann noch Schulung machen
oder ist das dann das, was ich nach der Schulung bin? Bin teilweise sehr verwirrt. Nee, also
was du nach der Ausbildung bist, was du nach der Ausbildung kannst, das hängt von zwei
Faktoren ab. Erstens mal welchen Betrieb du landest, was die so machen. Also wenn du jetzt
zum Beispiel bei irgendeiner, keine Ahnung, Embedded Microcontroller, Automobilindustrie,
Steuerungsanlagen, Low-Level-C-Programmiergeschichte bist, dann wirst du danach wahrscheinlich
nicht der krasse JavaScript-Frontend-Entwickler sein. Es sei denn, dich interessiert der Bereich
so brennen, dass du dich privat damit beschäftigst. Ja, und das ist eh was, da kommt man nicht
drum herum. Also alle richtig guten Leute, die ich kenne in diesem Bereich, die sind
das durch und durch. Also die sind nicht einfach nur tagsüber Programmierer oder tagsüber
Admin oder so. Die interessieren sich privat auch dafür und ich kann es dir nur aus meiner
Sicht sagen, also die meisten Sachen und die wichtigsten Sachen so Know-How-technisch
habe ich mir selber beigebracht, weil es mich interessiert hat und weil ich mir das
daheim angeguckt habe, die Praxiserfahrung, dass du dann damit quasi geübt bist und dass
du damit dann auch so belastbare Erfahrungen gesammelt hast. Ja, das hast du dann schon,
wenn du es auf der Arbeit regelmäßig verwendest. Also gerade das ganze Linux-Know-How, was
ich mittlerweile habe, das liegt natürlich hauptsächlich daran, weil ich beim Provider
meine Ausbildung gemacht habe und jeden Tag irgendwelche Linux-Kommando-Zeilen-Kram zusammen
gescriptet habe. Das war halt Praxis, Praxiserfahrung. Aber, dass ich überhaupt mal angefangen habe
mit Shell-Scripten und sonst was, das habe ich mir während der Ausbildung zum größten
Teil privat selbst beigebracht und dann auf der Arbeit täglich soweit verwendet, bis
ich dann die meisten Programme, die man also braucht, kenne, dass ich weiß, wir machen
einen Grab, gepiped nach Seed, gepiped nach WC, gepiped nach X-Args, was auch immer. Das
ist dann Übungssache. Aber gerade was Programmieren-Lernen angeht oder sowas, ja, Praxiserfahrung schön
und gut, aber neue Technologien sich angucken und auf dem aktuellen Stand bleiben, du musst
dich da privat für interessieren. Also die besten Leute, die ich kenne, sind das durch
und durch. Die interessieren sich beruflich dafür, die interessieren sich privat dafür
und ich habe so vieles schon einfach privat gelernt, weil es mich interessiert hat. Vieles,
was mir nie was auf der Arbeit bringen wird, ich glaube nicht, dass ich auf der Arbeit
jemals einen ESP32 Microcontroller programmieren muss oder sowas, aber vieles von dem, was
wir hier im Stream gemacht haben, habe ich danach auch in irgendeiner Art und Weise auf
der Arbeit verwenden können. Auch das ganze Frontendzeug, was wir hier machen, wird mir
letztendlich auf der Arbeit irgendwann mal was bringen. Und ja, das darf man nicht vergessen,
ihr habt schon recht, ihr habt schon recht, Chat, es ist viel ausprobieren, ausprobieren,
verkacken, feststellen, das geht nicht, warum geht es nicht, nachgucken und besser machen
und was immer hilft ist, gerade was Programmieren angeht, ist sich das angucken, was andere
Leute programmiert haben, von denen du weißt oder wo du traust, die können was oder das
taugt was. Also wenn man irgendeinen Framework lernen will, ist immer sinnvoll, sich tatsächlich
mal Beispielprojekte auf GitHub oder so anzugucken oder auch wenn man, wie gesagt, Bashscripting
sonst was lernen will, wenn man ein bisschen in die Linux-Administration hingeht, dann
ist es auch nicht verkehrt, sich Sachen anzugucken, von Leuten, die Ahnung davon haben, von denen
du weißt, dass die Ahnung davon haben, wie die das machen. Aber letztendlich, man muss
selbst ab und zu mal in die Kacke gegriffen haben, dass man weiß, wie es nicht geht.
Ne, das kann man so nicht sagen, das kann man so nicht sagen. Also das ist wichtig,
du musst eigentlich dich privat ein bisschen, ja mit den Gebieten, die dich interessieren
beschäftigen, um da weiterzukommen und auch neue Sachen zu lernen. Also man kann sich
nicht, auch später nicht, komplett auf irgendwie Schulungen vom Arbeitgeber verlassen, um neue
Technik zu lernen. Also zum Beispiel, als wenn wir jetzt mal irgendwie an neue Sachen
denken, irgendwie Kubernetes-Geschichten, Ansible-Server-Automatisierung, Terraform oder
irgendwelche Sachen in dieser Richtung, ganz ehrlich, wenn wir erst gewartet hätten, bis
wir eine Schulung bekommen hätten dafür, dann hätten wir es heute noch nicht im Einsatz.
Da kannst du dich nicht drauf verlassen, dass das passiert im Prinzip aus eigenem Interesse
an der Technik. Aber trotzdem ist die Ausbildung nicht nur dafür da, um was auf dem Papier
zu haben. Da hatte ich durchaus schon den einen oder anderen Azubi, der der Meinung
war, sie können das alles und sie brauchen am Ende nur irgendwie einen Zettel oder sowas
in der Hand zu haben. Ne, das ist es nicht so. Also man wird schon feststellen, dass
das private Gebastel ist das private Gebastel ist schön und gut und man lernt dabei auch
wirklich am meisten, aber die Business-Enterprise-Welt ist doch ein bisschen anders. Ja, man lernt
zum Beispiel in der Arbeit so Sachen wie, dass die bessere technische Ansatz nicht unbedingt
immer der ist, der gewollt ist. Ja, also wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen zwei Sachen
und du sagst ganz klar, das ist technisch die bessere Lösung, dann kann es durchaus
sein, dass es im Enterprise Strongs Umfeld passiert, dass die Lösung genommen wird,
die aus deiner Sicht schlechter ist. Das musst du auch erstmal lernen mit sowas umzugehen,
dass du sagst, hey, warum macht ihr so einen Schwachsinn? Und dann sagen die, ja wir haben
uns deine Bedenken angehört, aber wir wollen trotzdem lieber zu diesem Kackdienstleister
gehen, weil der uns ein SLA von 9,999 garantiert oder was auch immer. Also die Business-Dongs-Welt
läuft ein bisschen anders als was man daheim so bastelt. Und letztendlich braucht man halt
auch mal die Erfahrung, die muss man sammeln, zum Beispiel das was keiner gerne macht,
aber wo man einfach mal durch muss, dass man da entspannter wird bzw. weiß wie man damit
umgehen muss, ihr müsst mal bei einem Ausfall, wenn richtig Millionen gerade flöten gehen,
müsst ihr mal am Rechner sitzen, die Sache fixen, mit drei Abteilungsleiter hinter euch,
die euch auf den Monitor gucken. Das muss man einfach mal gemacht haben. Da muss man
einfach mal durch. Und sei es so, dass man die Konsequenz daraus zieht und sagt, ey,
das nächste Mal schicke ich die raus, was auch immer. Das sind so Sachen, die muss man
einfach mal erlebt haben, dass man weiß, wie man besser mit sowas umgehen kann. Und
das sind Dinge, die lernt man privat nicht. Und ich sage euch, das ist ganz besonders
toll, wenn du drei Leute hinter dir stehen hast, die quasi gerade die Millionen durch
die Hände rinnen sehen und dich im Minutentakt fragen, so kann man schon was abschätzen,
was dauert es denn noch? Ja, ist denn schon was zu erkennen? Und du hast dich gerade erst
so eingelockt und sagst, Leute, ich weiß ja nicht mal, was kaputt ist. Das sind so
Sachen, die lernst du vor Ort in der Ausbildung, wenn du Glück hast, wenn nicht später erst.
Aber das sind so Sachen, da musst du halt einfach mal durch. Also früher oder später
hat das Problem jeder mal. Und das sind Sachen, die lernt man nicht privat. Und wenn du das
geschafft hast, das ist nämlich Fikuni, das ist ein guter Punkt. Und wenn du sowas auf
die Reihe kriegst und dann in gewisser Weise auch weißt, okay, ich bin vielleicht nicht
der super krasse Pro, aber das, was ich mache, habe ich eigentlich ganz gut im Griff, dann
wirst du auch nicht mal so schnell nervös, wenn irgendwas nicht klappt oder so. Dann
weißt du einfach, okay, ich kriege die Sachen ganz gut hin. Und dann brauchst du dich auch
mal zu sagen, so nach dem Motto, Chef, jetzt nicht, ich gucke es mir an, aber ich kann
das nicht, wenn mir einer die ganze Zeit auf den Monitor guckt, lasst mich mal 15 Minuten
in Ruhe. Und dann machen die das auch. Aber das traut man sich am Anfang nicht. Dabei
ist das das Beste für alle. Ja, und das lernst du privat nicht. Also du lernst vielleicht
privat die Technologien und die Programmiersprache, die Technik vielleicht besser, vor allem
neue Sachen. Aber das ganze Businessumfeld, das lernst du privat halt nicht. Es ist auch
so ein Ding. Man kann oftmals nicht sagen, wie drücke ich jetzt aus, also Sachen, die
ich euch sage, würde ich so vielleicht nicht meinem Abteilungsleiter sagen. Wisst ihr,
wie ich meine? Also ich sage, wenn hier, wenn irgendwie einer hier was vorschlägt, was
Mist ist, dann sage ich Alter, Low IQ Chat schon wieder schreibt gegen den Mist oder
umgedreht, wenn ich irgendwas verkacke, dann auch so. Aber das geht nicht auf allen Ebenen
und gar nicht mal so sehr, weil man sagt, oh nee, das kann oder auch, aber nicht hauptsächlich,
weil du sagst, oh nee, das kann ich dem so und so gar nicht sagen, weil das ist ja der
Abteilungsleiter. Die Leute machen das oftmals, die sind ja gar nicht absichtlich planlos.
Also es ist auf der Arbeit oftmals so, wenn man dofe Fragen gestellt kriegt, dann liegt
das gar nicht so sehr daran, weil die dir dofe Fragen stellen wollen. Die wissen oftmals
nicht, wie sie es anders formulieren sollen. Da musste ich mich auch erstmal dran gewöhnen.
Ich bin eigentlich immer früher davon ausgegangen, Leute, die dofe Fragen stellen und nach 5
mal erklären, es nicht verstehen und immer die gleichen dofen Fragen stellen, die wollen
mich ärgern. Das ist aber gar nicht so. Die meisten sind einfach zu blöde und verstehen
es nicht. Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht ihnen ihre Aufgabe. Aber die meisten checken
es einfach nicht. Die fragen gar nicht absichtlich dummes Zeug. Die wissen es einfach nicht
besser und damit muss man halt auch umgehen können. Das muss man dann irgendwie diplomatisch
verpacken oder man kann zum Beispiel auch im Businessumfeld nicht 30 Minuten über irgendwas
abflamen, auch wenn es richtig scheiße ist. Man muss dann gucken, dass man, wenn man fertig
ist damit, noch irgendwie am Ende so ein bisschen was Versöhnliches sagt, dass man dann sagt,
man musste das jetzt ja einfach mal ansprechen, dass es da noch Probleme gibt, dass es noch
Verbesserungspotenzial gibt, was auch immer. Aber natürlich muss uns allen klar sein, wir
müssen da zusammen dran arbeiten, dass wir unserem Außendienst den besten Service bieten
können oder irgendwie so ein Stuss müsste dann am Ende noch dabei sagen, dass die Leute
nicht sauer sind. Und das lernt man halt da heimlich. Deswegen ist die Ausbildung nicht
verkehrt. Und es hat nichts damit zu tun, was auf dem Papier zu haben. Man lernt bei
der Ausbildung gerade die Sachen, die man halt privaten. Es geht ja nicht nur um die
Technik. Wenn es nur um die Technik gehen würde, wäre das ja einfach. Es geht halt
nicht nur um die Technik. Es geht auch um das ganze Business Enterprise Umfeld, was
man kennenlernen muss. Und das lernt man da heimlich. Ja, das stimmt, wenn es um Entwickler
geht auf jeden Fall. Also wenn man sich als Entwickler irgendwo bewirbt, dann würde ich
fast sagen, bei guten Sachen geht es nicht mehr ohne Github Account. Bei der Nuna 15
Klitsche um die Ecke, keine Ahnung, vielleicht schon. Aber Github Account ist auf jeden Fall
sehr, sehr sinnvoll. Privat tut man nicht dokumentieren. Ich dokumentiere auf der Arbeit
auch nicht. Ja, das ist auch das ist echt ein wichtiger Punkt. Wenn ich mir überlege,
wie schwer ich mir getan habe, in der Ausbildung teilweise nur ans Telefon zu gehen. Ich telefoniere
übrigens immer noch nicht gerne mit Leuten, deswegen arbeite ich auch nicht im Support
oder so ein Blödsinn. Aber ich habe mir in der Ausbildung unglaublich Probleme einfach
mal ans Telefon zu gehen, wenn einer anruft, weil ich immer Schiss hatte, so du weißt jetzt
ja eh nicht, was der will und du weißt nicht, was du dem sagen sollst. Es kommt heute noch
oft genug vor, dass ich keinen Plastenschimmer habe, was die von mir wollen. Aber in der
Ausbildung am Anfang zum Beispiel ist auch so ein Ding, habe ich immer so getan, als
wüsste ich es und habe es mir dann aufgeschrieben und jemand anderes gefragt, weil ich gedacht
habe, dem kannst du doch jetzt gar nicht sagen, dass du keinen Plan hast, wovon er spricht.
Und mittlerweile denke ich mir halt so, du kannst nicht alles wissen. Der soll es dir
halt mal ordentlich erklären. Und wenn du das den Leuten sagst, wenn du sagst, also
ich kenne mich in dem Bereich nicht aus, ich habe keine Ahnung, was du willst, dann erzählen
die das auch ordentlich. Das muss man sich aber auch erstmal trauen. Also man muss quasi
erstmal das Selbstvertrauen finden, zuzugeben, also man muss mit seinen Fähigkeiten soweit
zufrieden sein, dass man quasi bereit ist, auch öffentlich zuzugeben, dass man von was
keine Ahnung hat. Und eine Sache kann ich euch garantieren. Ihr werdet im Verlauf eures
Informatikordaseins oder eures ganzen Lebens werdet ihr von viel mehr Sachen keine Ahnung
haben, wie von Sachen, wo ihr Ahnung habt. Das heißt, keine Ahnung zu haben, ist eigentlich,
wenn man mal ehrlich ist, der Normalzustand. Ja, das gibt es auch. Das ist ein ganz anderes
Thema. Naja, was soll ich denn spielen? Soll ich etwa, soll ich etwa das hier spielen oder
was? Unter 2000 Spieler Peak? Ja, das muss man halt teilweise einfach auch mal sagen.
Oder so nach dem Motto, schickt mir das nochmal ein bisschen ausführlicher, keine Ahnung,
was ihr da habt oder wie die Kisten heißen oder wie man sagt, man soll das Ticket anders
schreiben, sodass man es versteht. Am besten war immer noch ein Anruf, ne, kein Anruf,
ne Mail, ne Mail, die ich gekriegt habe, wo einer Mail geschrieben hat, irgendwie, Hilfe,
das System geht nicht mehr. Das ist schon ewig her, das ist wirklich ewig her. Hilfe, das
System geht nicht mehr. Und die ist komplett falsch gewesen bei mir. Die musste woanders
hin. Also das war irgendwas von irgendeinem Krankenhaus oder so. Ich weiß aber, dass wir
wohl bei manchen auch irgendwie IT-technisch was im Krankenhaus zu tun haben, keine Ahnung.
Es war von irgendeinem Krankenhaus, wo wir eine gemeinsame Ahnung, Hilfe, wir brauchen
Unterstützung, das System geht nicht mehr. Und dann habe ich zurückgeschrieben, so nach
dem Motto, also ich glaube, sie sind bei mir komplett falsch. Ich weiß aber auch nicht,
wo sie jetzt genau hinmüssen, weil mir ist nicht klar, um welches System geht es denn
überhaupt. Und da war die Antwort absolut high IQ, natürlich das System, mit dem wir
täglich arbeiten. Da habe ich mir auch gedacht, keine Ahnung. Ich habe das dann weitergeleitet
an die Hotline, habe gesagt, warte mal, ich habe keine Ahnung, was die will und nie wieder
was von gehört. Das System, mit dem wir täglich arbeiten. Super, da weißt du Bescheid, ne.
So Leute, Bettke, 20.20 Uhr, wir sehen uns morgen, machts gut, bis denn, see you.